derek chauvin
found guilty on every single count
or at least all the murder charges when
they announced the verge was coming in
turn the tv on i sat down and we all sat
in suspense waiting for them to make the
announcement
and the judge came in and he read the
verdict on the count of murder in the
second degree
guilty murder third degree guilty and
manslaughter and second degree
guilty and i think a lot of people
expected this because the
the verdict came back so soon as soon as
this verdict came out
we saw people in the streets you know
cheering celebrating and crying
now they're marching already i don't
know if there's going to be riots
i think there likely still will be riots
because all of the people are outside
it's all that really matters a lot of
people don't care about whether there's
a verdict or not
and some of these organizations and
activists are saying it's not justice
obama said it's not justice aoc said
it's not justice
true justice would be if floyd was alive
and the whole system has to be reformed
so these people are out marching i think
it's possible that eventually the police
say you need to stop and go home they
say a few they throw a brick boom more
riots
it's going to be particularly
interesting to see how the public reacts
when they realize that nothing will
satiate the violence
we got a lot about this to talk about
there's a lot of stories maxine water
was defended by democrats over her
threat threats against the jury and
incitement to insurrection and we have
to break this down
and uh man it's gonna get brutal well
we have a great guest today we have
former trump staffer and current uh well
i guess you're running for congress in
illinois 16th catalina love you want to
introduce yourself real quick
yes thanks so much for having me i'm
running for congress in
illinois 16th district a former
appointee to the department of commerce
and midwestern girl you are running
against the infamous adam kinzinger
yes he was one of the 10 who voted to
impeach
president trump and is just all around
uh
you know weak need backstabbing
there's still some time until that it's
the primary right is that yes
yes so it'll be next year uh we're
running in 2022
and and it's been a great great run so
far a lot of people
are so fed up with the way that you know
not only politicians on
all sides of the aisle have been acting
lately but certainly uh
some of these kind of traitors on the
republican party side so
we're really excited and we've had a ton
of energy and support
and we can't wait right on we'll we'll
we'll talk all about it we got ian he's
chilling yeah what up dudes
ian crossland ian was pissed i was
i was like ian stopped swearing i was
out of my mind tim earlier was like well
they already
they already came to a verdict and i was
like well i guess he's innocent then i
guess they found him innocent that was
my only because it was
so fast but i guess getting them guilty
on all equally is possible it's just
shocking it's like clown world
i would i would have been if it would
we'll save it we'll save it yeah because
we're going to go off
we got lydia i'm also here i'm so
excited to have catalina she's just like
freaking inspiring she's about my age
and she's making it happen
i'm excited all right before we get into
the big story we have a sponsor today
and i'm
eternally grateful to virtual shield
check out the link in the description
below for virtual shield at
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
50
off for life a virtual private network
service what this does
you open this program it's relatively
easy you just download it you click it
you open it boom you're connected
and it helps keep your data safe from
prying eyes be it
hackers the government major
corporations that want to spy on you
it's a basic level of security for you
while you browse the internet and i
always describe it as this
you don't expect people to break into
your house but still lock your doors and
window
a vpn service like virtual shield is
a good way to have that basic level of
security so again go to
surfinginternetsafe.com they say stay
home
stay protected 50 off for life it is
only 2.50
per month you can enjoy 24 months of
online security from the world's easiest
and fastest vpn
for only 59.88 that's over 77 off wow so
i guess it's even a better deal
plus you get 50 of all add-ons and other
great discounts
on our other plans we also proud to
announce that this month all discounts
are guaranteed for life that means 50
off for as long as you're a customer
my friends virtual shield is awesome
they've been a sponsor of
my work since i literally started on
youtube with my other channels
so i'm eternally grateful that they are
a continuing sponsor of the show if
you're looking for a vpn check them out
again
surfinginternetsafe.com and don't forget
to go to timcast.com and become a member
just at the top you can see this member
area members area click that
and you can see a whole bunch of really
awesome segments that you can only
listen to
at timcast.com so we will have a bonus
segment coming up after this show at
temcast.com become a member
help support our work in the event that
we get banned because
you know bands are happening uh and it's
in it's
serious it may be getting better but it
comes and goes in waves so we set this
up in the event
we do get purged like everybody like
many others but we're gonna be doing a
lot more uh great work on the channel
with new shows
new podcasts and uh even comedy music so
uh check it out and don't forget to like
share subscribe hit the notification
bell
and leave us a good review if you're
listening on itunes or spotify enough
it is time to talk news i wanted to save
the the
to keep the intro to a minimum because
we are about to go off on this
jury finds derek chauvin guilty of
murder
no swearing no swearing i couldn't
believe it dude no i could believe it i
absolutely could believe it the jury was
threatened
maxine waters threatened the jury the
rioters threaten the jury
and there are left-wing journalists
right now saying
the only reason we got this verdict is
because we spent months out in the
streets and i'm like they're even
admitting it it was the threat of
violence and destruction that resulted
in the jury saying
derek chelvin should go to prison on
second degree murder
now i will i want to be fair they're
getting on the felony murder rule
arguing that it was assault against
george floyd
and because it was felony assault and
george floyd died therefore it's murder
okay i think there's maybe an argument
of assault but this is what
really makes me think this is nuts we
watched the video
in great detail the defense showed the
video george floyd was resisting arrest
a bystander even said
you can't win man just get in the car no
joke the prosecution and the defense
show that in closing arguments
a guy yelling to floyd to stop resisting
some random bystander
so i'm sitting here like why is the
prosecution showing george floyd
actively resisting and bystanders saying
stop resisting
so you mean to tell me that a cop is
trying to arrest somebody
for a counterfeit for potential under
under the influence and now resisting
arrest
and it's assault if the guy says hold me
on the ground hold me on the ground hold
me on the ground like george floyd did
and then chauvin holds him on the ground
and they say that's felony assault
oh and he died murder now he's gonna go
to prison
so i'll tell you this i'm not a big fan
i'm not interested in defending the
state
or police institutions as a whole my
interest is is in the individual
derek chauvin and his rights and i'm not
happy that you know about what happened
to george floyd but i will tell you
if you got a problem with the state and
the system and the policing
take it up with the state the system and
the policing but now you know it
happened
the state literally won it was the state
of minnesota
versus derek chauvin and the state won
their case why
because leftists extremists activists
went out
burned down their city leftist journals
are the ones saying this
their being on the ground and engaging
these activities resulted in this
verdict maxine waters making these
threats
and so the jury sided with the state
chauvin's one man you got a problem with
the actions of an individual officer
that crossed the line by all means hold
him accountable
but chauvin is acting as per the rules
of the police department
arrest somebody if they commit a crime
if they resist arrest here's the force
you can use
i don't see how throwing one man under
the bus is going to solve any of these
problems
and i still think we're going to see
riots so nothing gets solved in long run
other than a bunch of weak and terrified
jurors
who just say guilty because i'd rather
not have my house burned down
i i think i agree with obama that it was
not justice
uh and uh alexandria cortez yeah but
justin
obama but right you're taking it the
other direction yeah i am taking it the
other direction barack
because it wasn't barack obama said true
justice is about much more than a single
verdict aoc said
this is not justice because they need to
keep the grift going
they need to always be angry well think
about i mean think about everything that
led up to
all this i mean even when you look at
the riots and all this
when you have people that are not firm
on people going to jail i mean we saw
massive amounts of damage millions of
dollars
this was obviously incredibly
politicized and then to your point about
maxine waters
when you have all these kind of like
tectonic plates almost
uh building up this pressure and then
ultimately have
you know the the media on talking about
this
and being in favor of the way it should
go
quote quote unquote and then you have
politicians speaking out
and then on top of that all this civil
unrest that's kind of really creating
this
this uh pressure um it really is
concerning
on who is choosing uh
you know is this gonna happen a lot
i mean when does it when does the the
writing and the
everything that led up to this when does
it end
you know the one the one uh they say you
know got what god closes the door he
opens a window
the one thing i can see is i think the
second amendment's about to get a whole
lot stronger
if these if these people are going to go
on riot i really don't see why they
would not
because you have the dante wright
incident as well so they're not going to
be satisfied with just this
i think it would have been way worse but
now i can only imagine more liberals are
going to be like
need to buy a gun so i guess there's
that at least
in it to your point i tweeted this
or i should say i tweeted this and it
works to your point i said let this be a
lesson to all police
you will be charged you will be
imprisoned when i saw that story about
kim potter is her name i think the cop
in the dante right thing i'm like why is
she why is anyone surprised this is
happening to her
i think if you're a cop watching this
happen to chauvin and his other officers
and you choose to stay there hey man
it's a free country you do what you want
to do
but there's only so much i can do to to
defend you
when you know what the mob wants you
know the politicians are going to give
it to them
and you know there will not be a fair
trial you you expect to
to get passed through this i don't think
so well we're seeing so much
of a i mean at all campaigning i i talk
with a lot of law enforcement
we're in such a you know back the blue
type of area where
you have so many people either retiring
from the la from the police force and
law enforcement
people they have shortages now people
don't even want to
join uh the force i think eventually
i mean these things need to be done in
an honest way
and and that's just not being it's just
not happening right now
it's it's perfectly in line with what
the left wanted right defund the police
abolish the police and if that doesn't
work
drive the police out with threats and
intimidation and terror
the court of public opinion is making me
nervous it's
it's really powerful i knew it was
powerful in 2006 when i saw youtube
videos and that you could get 50
000 people to call somebody at the same
time on the same day
yeah and then the next day do it again
or order pizzas
yeah just in it and it causes serious
problems take all your money out of the
bank at the same time on the same day
just crash a bank
on any given day any youtuber i mean you
could do that
and i know these are mutually exclusive
but also why was it encouraged
i mean you had encouragement on on the
the blm and the riots and the protesting
from from
all these different angles as well and i
know it's a little different from the
actual
you know verdict today but these things
are being encouraged
and that is a big problem at what point
are are your elected officials going to
stand up and say
no it's not going to happen until
regular people say something
and they won't because they're scared so
you know we we
ian and i got an argument the other day
where i was like
if the people of minneapolis the twin
cities of minnesota will not
personally stand up and say i support
the police and this is wrong
then the police have no support now you
can whisper it to your friends ain't
enough
these people don't want to put blue
lives matter flags up they want to put
american flags up because they know they
get targeted
okay then the squeaky wheel gets the
grease the reason why it's being
encouraged
major corporations know there is no
opposition if they come out
and they what ben and jerry's then ice
cream company yelling at me about racist
cops
like i don't care dude you guys make
cookie ice cream i i
don't need to hear from you about the
police department it's fine i guess i
don't care market how you want to market
i just think it's absurd that someone's
like i'm gonna start an ice cream
company
and my marketing pitches you're a racist
and evil buy my ice cream
but the reason they do that is because
there's zero opposition so what's the
downside
if they come out and they say go riot
and go in the streets
no conservative will do anything they
might complain about it i mean we did
have the conservatives burning all their
nike gear when colin kaepernick took a
knee
but for the most part they don't so
conservatives are
staying home minding their own business
not organizing and the major
corporations the big tech companies and
the politicians know their only threat
is from the left
so they give the left whatever they want
normally if you were to tell people to
go riot
which is a crime i mean i don't know
rioting is a crime well
the word riot that that's not
necessarily a crime right
you have to massage the truth again get
more confrontational yes walk faster
when people are burning down buildings
tell them to do more be more active
like it's supposed to be illegal to
incite violence but to have
maxine waters telling people if we don't
get a murder one charge which he wasn't
even charged with
or a conviction for murder one which she
wasn't charged with that we should
what she what was her quote do you guys
know offhand that we should push harder
that we
should get we should get more active and
get more confrontational get more
confrontational she's talking to rioters
that's
she's and they're still out there right
now so that they're that right
right now as they're marching around i
don't know exactly
if it'll escalate or what the deal is i
got to tell you man
i kind of i i i wasn't really expecting
a verdict this fast
i re i i my video today was like oh
they're preparing who knows when the
verdict will be and
my my over at teamcast.com and then i
get a text and it's like the verdict is
coming in an hour and i'm like
what it's been a day it's not even i
think it was ten hours of deliberations
yeah it was so so when i when i heard
that it was that fast i was like it's
either going to be
guilty on all counts or not guilty on
all counts it is too soon for a hung
jury
there's no way the jurors went in and
they were like half of us are for guilty
and half are for not guilty and we'll
never change our minds okay let's go
home hung jury
too soon so i was kind of like maybe
it'll be not guilty because
they're bringing in the national guard
to downtown minneapolis right now
they're
why would they be moving the national
guard and i'm like so it must be not
guilty
then i heard guilty and i'm like they're
they they knew the verdict was guilty
and they're still bringing in the
national guard you know uh ben shapiro
tweeted something
amid all this he said the fact that i'll
paraphrase the fact that we all knew
that our cities would burn based on the
outcome of this
of this trial is an indictment of
of of our country or society or
something that effect yeah that's
absolutely true
of where we are now what but it even
goes into
what happened recently with you know
georgia and just kind of all these
policy measures that
people are are choosing sides and
corporations are choosing sides and
people are being kind of pressured again
where you're seeing this on every
type of and politics is infiltrating
kind of
every aspect of our lives now and and i
don't think it's ever been that way and
it shouldn't be that way
but but did you see what happened with
coke like didn't come out and actually
say
like georgia's voter law new voter law
is racist and then conservatives were
like uh we're gonna buy pepsi and they
went wait wait
we must find common we must find common
ground see that's the thing
the concern so the republican party is
has much less people than the democratic
party
it's shifted quite a bit in the last
election it started to invert
democrats are joining the republicans
republicans are doing great recruitment
but you mostly have moderates and
independents that sometimes lean right
that's how republicans end up winning
these people don't do anything they
don't speak up they don't say anything
they keep shopping
coca-cola could you know could pepsi
literally made a commercial
where their protesters going around
handing out pepsis
and they see no repercussions for this i
mean actually the woke left got mad at
him about that so they had to like
apologize for
having was it kendall kendall jenner
kendall that was
oh yeah no is it kylie i don't know i
don't know any of these people i never
watched that handing out pepsis
it's it's this simple conservatives
aren't organized
moderates don't organize disaffected
liberal types
actually there's a decent amount of
disrupted liberals who are speaking up
but by nature as a disability liberal
they're complaining about something
so long as this group is just like loose
knit and passively in agreement but not
actively going out talking about things
standing up going outside
then there's no downside it's it's it's
the it's uh uh
do you guys know what pascal's wager is
negative you you do
you do right so it's basically this dude
was like
if i believe in god and i die
and it's none of it was real or true
then what does it matter
but if i believe in god and i die and it
is true i get to go to heaven
he says now if i don't believe in god
and it's not true
it doesn't matter and if i don't believe
in god and it is true
well then i go to hell so your safest
bet
is to be you know believe in god or be
religious
it's not necessarily a fantastic
argument but i bring this up because we
have what what i call
i'll call the critical the critical
theorists wager or the social justice
wager
if you are on the right and uh
you know you stand up for your rights
you will likely be cancelled or banned
if you are on the right and you do
nothing nothing happens
you end up losing the left ends up
gaining ground if you're on the left you
stand up for what you
and you don't stand up for what you
believe in the left still charges
through gets whatever they want
and if you're on the left and you stand
up and scream you will likely get
whatever you want so
you're celebrated right so this this
this wager is very obvious
if you want to run a business right now
in this environment
your best bet is just to feign leftism
because there's no negative
repercussions
and that's awful because you look at
and you make a really good point because
you know commerce and business and
services and products these were things
that were supposed to unite us
as americans or unite us as people
right when you're going to ben and
jerry's well nowadays now you are asking
well
what were you talking about in politics
but before you're like i just want my
double chocolate chip ice cream
you could sit down to ben and jerry's
and look over to a random stranger and
be like which one you get
right now it's like who'd you vote for
to the cashier even
i mean that's what it turns into oh what
i'm researching every
single company that has spoken out and
what are their
their stances now and it's awful and i
and
it's it's bad because as a somebody who
works in business
our product for example helps kids and
that's it
and it's like well is it that's not
republican or democrat you're just
trying to
you're trying to create a product and
you're trying to solve an issue and
you're
and there's a demand for it simple as
that it's supposed to unite us
yeah so you've made the point that
politics has gotten into everything and
this is something that troubles me as
well
this is not the way it's supposed to be
and the fact that we have to do things
like ask who
did you vote for that creates suspicion
it weakens our society from the bottom
up i hate to see it
i i look at what happened with with
chauvin and the one thing
i think the perspective of the left is
that like all cops all the time are
abusing their power
and they don't understand like why
arrests happen
and they keep saying things like if if
derek chauvin didn't put his knee on
george floyd's neck
then floyd would be alive today the
prosecution
this was actually debunked very early on
two things the eight was it eight
minutes 46 seconds was debunked
actually longer it was 9 minutes 29
seconds i think it was but the other
thing that was debunked was that the
knee was on floyd's neck the whole time
it wasn't
in the video you can actually see some
in some periods the knee moved off the
neck
but the left uh i mean they
they want to believe in these uh
tribalist
i don't i don't i honestly don't know
why they don't they don't investigate
they don't read the stuff
they just assume whatever the media says
is true i see him paired on social media
and then what you get is blind rage in
support of the tribe
you know the leftist tribe no matter
what i was talking to a friend of mine
and she said uh you know i
i don't even want to talk about what we
were talking about but she was like i'm
just gonna accept it
at face value and i was like yeah you're
just gonna believe the first thing they
tell you
the government and she's like i just
don't have the energy to
investigate and and that was
that was it i'll put out i do i'll put
it this way they say that george floyd
would uh still be alive if shoving it
put his knee on his back
george flo would still be alive if he
didn't resist arrest or do drugs maybe
yeah or take a bunch of fentanyl maybe
maybe maybe he would have killed a kid
and
got behind the wheel of the car and
drove into some family walking across
the street yeah
he was doing drugs in the car yeah it
was and
the the defense made an interesting
point that we don't know how much
fentanyl he took
the the nor fentanyl in a system was the
metabolite of the fentanyl he had
already taken so
that means he had taken some like a long
time before this incident occurred
so look i'm not happy about what
happened i don't like the idea that a
cop is trying to arrest somebody and
they die
the cops shouldn't be killing people and
there should be a level of scrutiny the
issue i suppose is
this will not reform the police
department it won't i guess what the
left is going for
is if you can't beat them burn them to
the ground if they can't get
the police department abolished then
they're going to try and force
every cop out and right now i gotta say
the smartest position for the police is
probably just to leave what is this
are they like okay this is high
conspiracy but is this like a corporate
takeover
like do they want private police the
squad you see that breaking story
you see that the squad members buying
all the private security oh of course
yeah
this is like turning into a third world
country uh you know my family
my mom came from guatemala and they have
the private police force now overtakes
the public police force because you
don't really know
you know whose side the the cops are on
it's not
meaning to laugh but it's just you get
to this point where it's
you're seeing elements of that here
in you know the greatest country in the
world and this is what separates
us from these
third world countries i'd be willing to
bet
a bunch of our libertarian and anarchist
friends who've been on the show
are going to be cheering for the idea
that the police will crumble from this
because they genuinely believe private
policing is better i'm not one of those
people i'm i'm fairly libertarian little
l not big l
leaning slightly to the left and i think
the reason the police department works
is that they're neutral arbiters
they're not perfect the individuals can
be racists the individuals can be
bigoted
we want to we want we want to deal with
that we don't want those things lawsuits
exist as well and there's a challenge
with poverty
when somebody who's poor gets pulled
over and they can't afford to pay a
ticket then they go to jail it creates a
cycle it's very it's problematic
but when you have two people fighting
and a cop walks up he's not there to be
on anyone's side like is it the laws
that's what you did
go away or you're under arrest right
well in aoc and the squad
they all talk about equality and you
know no classism and all this well
that's exactly what they're trying to do
when you talk about private police
forces who is able to afford a private
police force
obviously people who are wealthy and
have money
but then yet your your policies and what
you talk about all the time is about
equality and and no classes and yeah and
all i mean it just it's completely
it's complete hypocrisy to t
this is what will happen they will
defund the police they will use the
chauvin case
as as an example and they're going to
march and they're going to say see
and then once the police are defunded
the rich people who don't care
are going to hire you know g4s or
securitas or something
and they're going to have a couple guys
in suits with glasses outside their
house and they're going to worry about
anything
you we talked about this last year
during the riots
you know private security would actually
punch a cop on your behalf
if you get a if you get a legit private
security company these guys are getting
paid
you know low to mid six figures
depending on who the client is right
these guys look they're wearing suits
they got sunglasses ear pieces legit
security for high-profile individuals
if a cop tried arresting these security
guards would shove a cop to the ground
they they would absolutely assault an
officer because they don't respect some
guy getting 30k a year in new york city
or 40k
when they're getting 400k and they're
working for a prince or a celebrity
they're like nah this guy's got billions
of dollars he'll bail me out i don't got
to worry about it
my company will take care of me so when
the police are defunded
and they don't respond to the calls of
the poor people anymore who suffers
well it's going to be the black
community it's going to be a latino
community right it's going to be the
poor community in general
and the rich people are going to be
sitting there in their infinity pools
not caring well they just found that
something i want to say something like
80
of people who are surveyed these black
people in these communities want
more police presence right they don't
want the police to go away
well it was the same thing with the
hispanic community when you look at you
know voter demographics i mean
i come from a you know 40 miles outside
of the city of chicago where you're
seeing
very high crime rates all the time
nobody's talking about that crime
hush hush right they talk about these
kind of instances that happen
uh every once in a while
but the same thing happened in the
hispanic community which is why a lot of
people started voting more conservative
because they come from countries where
there is no law and order they're
leaving these places where
they don't trust their law enforcement
we
again have that public trust
and and they're you know people are
chipping away at that
i love i love the idea of socialists and
leftists
condemning the state right now when the
state literally won its case
the state versus derek chauvin the state
is the winner
they're complaining about us i see these
tweets they're like
it was an agent of the state who who
committed a murder and it's good to see
they should not be allowed to do that
and i'm like
it's the state who also won from the gun
to the bus also
if you're a socialist and you want
socialized everything yeah
then shouldn't you be happy with a
socialized law enforcement
system well apparently not the the great
part of it is local cops
like i was in chile for a while and
it's national cops only in that country
so if you have a problem a dog is
barking or bites someone on the corner
you've got feds
there like with brown out uniforms on
ready to take you to federal prison
and lock like it's federal all the way
down and it's terrifying
that if you jaywalk or some minor crime
the feds are on you down there
that's like how it is in most of the
world i think i'm not i'm not much of a
legal expert
no you're absolutely right in in places
like central america
you have you know armed military police
m16s on the street corner and in parks
i mean that's normal to those people
that's one thing that a lot of people
are saying and they're still crime
yeah there are people tweeting like it
took us too long to get this verdict
330 days or something like that i don't
think it was 330 days it was uh
oh yeah yeah was it 330 days yeah uh
that's what they were saying and my
attitude is like
you mean you got it done that fast in
many countries there's no trial
perspective they're like dude go to go
to go to some of these countries you
think
south america a cop who's working for
the state is going to face punishment
for anything
no they're brought their bribery is
rampant down there too yeah these guys
can literally walk into poor
neighborhoods and shoot someone in the
face and they're not gonna get in
trouble in the united states
they burn the country down and get away
with it when it comes down to we are a
country of law and order and this is
lawlessness when you're seeing all these
riots when you're
and on top of that even the the verdict
today where these issues are complex
obviously
right there's no back to your point
about click bait and people who just
don't want to dive deeper or see each
other as humans or talk about these
things
in a substantive way it comes down to we
need to enforce
the law and and there's a real precedent
that's being set now
just again with all the political
tensions leading up to this
of what is kind of where we're going to
be moving forward and do we want to be
this country where it burns to the
ground
uh do we want to be a country where the
the
people have questions about a verdict
because
of the political unrest leading leading
up to this and even during
right you had the media maxine waters
again
uh there are some real questions here
that are setting
kind of the tone for the next uh years
to come and what is our country going to
look like 50 years from now
here's what i i find kind of funny uh so
you're you're running for congress
yeah you know and uh can i ask you how
old you are or are you
too old yeah i'm turning 28 in a month
may 5th yes thank you cinco de mayo
yes little firecracker so here's
not as cool as fourth or july i find
this kind of funny though so like
you you're uh would you consider
yourself to be pro police pro police
yeah well yeah i'm pro law enforcement
absolutely and pro law and order
as a more of a principle behind that but
so you would support
local police departments absolutely i
just find it funny that the squad
there's this story from four hours ago
about them hiring private security while
talking about
defunding the police right and it's a
republican candidate who's like support
our public law enforcement system
yeah like i i'm not i just think i don't
know
how much you've got so much evidence of
hypocrisy among
aoc and the squad that you just i
at a certain point won't someone on the
won't these leftists who support them
won't their heads explode from the
cognitive dissonance
well yeah well because they're the
elites now and i will tell you too
you know i've done ride-alongs with our
local law enforcement i did one here in
d.c
a while ago and i visited the county
jails like i'm i'm telling you you're
you're face-to-face not face-to-face
obviously you have glass screen but
with like murderers and ice detainees
who have
possible terrorist ties like these are
criminals
and then you look at you know in dc i
saw you know three people die
that night it was a saturday night and
just what you think about
the everyday job of a law enforcement
officer
is is something that and what i think
about too when you're talking about the
hypocrisy
you know the left is all about empathy
and feeling and all that
we are not even understanding what the
average cop has to go through every day
especially in big cities
i mean i live in a sleepier town but
crime rates are going up in the suburbs
crime rates are going up in
traditionally small
neighborhoods it is a real issue and
we're not looking at
them as humans it's have you seen that
letter that's gone viral
they say supposedly it's from a former
police officer
they say that the these people on the
left expect a cop to be a medical expert
to be a doctor to know all the signs of
a seizure of
asphyxiation they expect them to be a
psychologist to know how to deal with a
mentally ill person who's on a rampage
they expect them to be able to do all of
these jobs
to use just enough force to be a
brazilian jiu jitsu expert that can take
down a six foot one
220 pound guy when you're five foot 940
pounds that's that's derek chovin they
expect you to have
all of the power capabilities and the
knowledge of all of these different
fields
when you were literally a dude or a lady
who was set who was told if someone
breaks the law and they can
you know arrest them they're not doctors
shelving was not a doctor
how was he supposed to know any of this
stuff it's crazy to me because i
you mentioned going on the ride alongs
with these law enforcement i did uh a
night crawling
in chicago oh my gosh you're from you
understand that yeah yeah so for those
that don't know what night crawling is
it's like
you go out in the middle of the night
you track the police scanner and you you
look for local
stories typically it's like crime and
things like that in one night
i think i saw what like five five
murders five crime scenes in chicago
in one night it was like take your pick
what do you want to do
sit in the car and you'll be like oh
there's a murder no let's not go to that
one because
you know that one's 15 minutes away
another murder that was five minutes
away
and we pull up and each and every time i
see these cops people don't get it man
it's it's dark out there are people
gathering on the streets you don't know
who they are what they're doing
you're called to a house that was
riddled it's riddled with bullets we
went to one house
this was kind of scary because i'm from
chicago i know i know
these neighborhoods and we roll up and
we see a couple squad cars
the cops walk up to a house bullet holes
all throughout the front of the building
two people dead
and there's like 30 people on each side
of the of the block
and i'm like now this cop here with one
other guy who arrived on scene
knows active shooting possibly dead
people
and now there's like 30 people gathering
and he doesn't know which one of them
may be the maybe the murderer
and you think that guy's supposed to go
in there with the full capabilities of
martial arts marksmanship medical
expertise and psychological expertise to
deal with situations like that
it's insane to me the level of i should
say the lack of empathy
for how awful that job can really be and
then when you
exacerbate it on a public
stage you have people spitting at cops
now
you have that culture just completely uh
changing the dynamics of of law
enforcement as a whole i mean i get
families all the time
of you know wives of police officers or
even my police officer friends where
they're like i don't
i didn't do anything wrong and yet
people spit in my face
because of all this politicizing
politicization
and and this being on such a mass scale
and and that's you know really sad too
you see it a lot in military as well
and and it's a very tough we're not
seeing people again there's no empathy
and no
human perspective they assume because
yeah
uh you know what i'll rephrase what i
was going to say
how many viral videos have you seen of
police brutality
a lot 40 in my life
40 50 and the main reason has to look
for them not many lately
i'd say i've seen a lot yeah they're and
they're increasing every year
yeah just since 2012 i've seen them all
a ton
a bunch now here's here here's the issue
you've got 300 and you know 30 million
people in this country 200 some odd
million 220 million adults or whatever
there's going to be more police
interactions more police interactions
means you will have accidental
deaths you have negligent actions you
have
overt criminal acts from some officers
but we're talking about what's like 100
million police interactions per year
and like 20 you know unarmed guys you
know guys being getting shot
2019 people don't seem to take into
consideration
that they may see all these videos
they'll see all these news stories
you know what there's never a new story
about local officer
uh household lady cross street right
local officer pulls someone pulls an 18
year old kid for speed and gives him a
warning and
and the kid the kid turns things around
stop speeding
so you know you've seen some videos
where it's like a cop plays basketball
with the local kids yeah it's
heartwarming i've seen a few of those
but what you what we don't see is the
everyday day-to-day of what the cop does
from the perspective of extremely
violent crimes yeah and routine law
enforcement
where's the viral story in the viral
video where a cop pulls someone over
walks up and says ma'am you were
speeding you were going you know eight
over in a in a 40.
please don't do it again have a nice day
that happens all the time
but no one cares about the monotony and
and it's it's kind of like how we take
i'm sorry no that's basically it's kind
of like how we take our physical health
for granted
not everybody was rude of me i know uh
but like
i stepped on glass earlier oh my god i
just take it out of my foot
i spent time thinking like i don't think
about
when i'm healthy i don't think every
moment like i am so healthy this is so
great
but as soon as it hurts it is the
biggest deal in the world to me right
bro it's like when you got a stuffed
nose
and you're like and you think about like
when man i remember what was it like
when my nose wasn't stuffed do you
really think about it yeah
yeah like most of the time that's what's
happening with these brutality issues as
soon as one happens it's like an injury
that everyone is focused on
and when one instance gets a hundred
million views that's like it's like
it's like it happened 100 million times
right especially with all of the
political agenda pushing as well
and it's the same thing with guns i mean
you look at
the the mass shootings for example it's
the same
thing i think there's always kind of
this there's always a narrative
behind it and and that's concerning
because then again what to what extent
is public opinion
determining things not actually the law
you mentioned
law and order yeah i like that phrase
because i think a lot of times people
focus on is the law being followed but
yeah but also is order being adjudicated
is it orderly because a bad law is out
of order
so i think people are out of touch with
law like right
we can't make we can't even offer up a
law to congress as people we have to
rely on this like 600 people no no bro
bro it's it's so far beyond that let me
let me pull up this uh this this next
story which hits exactly at your point
oh yeah
democrats block resolution censuring
maxine waters for chauvin trial comments
keeping things in line with the
discussion at hand but basically what
you were saying ian
is that even when we have maxine waters
incite insurrection
telling people to do more than they
already are when mass riots are underway
the republicans can't even wag their
finger at her
accenture is a finger wag so we're at a
point now where we have ridiculous
nonsensical laws
they don't like the war on drugs for
instance is insane
we we struggle to get anything done in
terms of repealing most of these laws it
doesn't really happen
or decriminalizing things and then you
have when a politician on the democrat
side it tends to be
you know the the rule for the left they
get away with all this stuff
you can't even get republicans to do
anything or be able to do anything
about this and that's you know kind of
leads into why i'm running too
because we don't have people with
backbones i mean you're getting to a
point where
we saw the president of the united
states being impeached for a second
time for let's say
he said the words that he said peaceful
go peacefully
cheer on politicians and then you have
even republicans
you know one of them that i'm i'm
unseating here adam kinzinger
going and voting for impeachment or
stripping marjorie taylor green for
example a congresswoman outside of
georgia
for stripping her of committee when
people have that much power or when you
have one side
with that much power that is actually
determining people's lives and the way
that our country is going
that's a huge problem because you do not
have two
peop two opinions that are being taken
into account and to your point is
you're spot on where we don't even have
republicans standing firm
on half this stuff this is why i said
you know i've been saying for some time
i don't think i'd vote republican in
2022
depends well if you were in my district
you would i would you're right i i i
would
because uh you're younger energetic
and you seem principled uh i'd have to
go through all your policies though to
be fair but
no i look at i look at mitch mcconnell
lindsey graham i look at kevin mccarthy
the best kevin mccarthy could offer up
as a wag wag the finger at maxine waters
censure spare me marjorie taylor green
introduced a bill to expel maxine waters
yeah now of course that's not gonna
happen
for all the criticism people can level
uh can can levy or
throw at uh margery taylor green by all
means at least
she's doing something right maxine
waters flew from california into a riot
and said get more confrontational if we
don't get a first degree murder
conviction that is insane
even cnn's chris saliza crystal
criticized maxine water for doing this
and what happens the best republicans
can do is i would like to introduce
a bill to censure maxine waters
democrats denied
moving on we didn't get a first degree
murder conviction by the way so if they
do get more confrontational she's on the
hook for that
yeah well nothing's gonna happen i'm i'm
so angry at the two-party system
this i'm you sound like you're about to
say something where are we gonna now go
ahead
there's it's like a stranglehold you
know george washington warns
overtly about the danger of two-party
politics that
that one gets a little bit of a majority
and then takes complete control of our
government but
i want to see like six or seven small
groups so that if four of these groups
decide
no we are going to censure you can't
stop me from censoring this
congresswoman that called for violence
but our founders also i feel like they
didn't want to see
a multiple party system because they saw
that in europe as well
and the detriment to that is that you
have too many
factions now and people as humans
gravitate i think towards like one or or
another but to your point the best part
i think the biggest silver lining about
all this and just from a political
perspective
also in being a candidate is that you're
seeing so many people now
everyday americans stepping up because
they're so
frustrated with the way things are going
and they're like you know what
i want to run because i want to take i
want to unseat these people
i don't think they're doing their job
and we are we the people
are holding people accountable now when
politics gets into everybody's personal
lives
they are finally caring and this is the
way i think our experiment
is supposed to go we're take you're
seeing this uh
this movement happening this disruption
and it's really challenging right now
but we're also seeing uncovered and
we're taking back the power
and and i think that's it's really
positive in that way and
um unfortunately like three parties
wouldn't work like you can't
um and i don't mean unfortunately i'm
running as a absolutely as a
conservative but now you're even seeing
like
different factions of conservatism for
example like adam kinzinger he is a
democrat why is he a republican
right like we are we need to take back
our party
and the way that our party is moving is
this america first law and order
free market enterprise system
uh you know just everybody thriving from
an economic perspective
and and that's where our country is
going that's where the republican party
is going but we need to take that back
it's it's one thing to be anti-trump
because i can understand that people
don't
a lot of people didn't like the guy it's
another thing to be
what can you know kenzinger and he's so
for those under families is republican
in illinois who just basically sides
with democrats all the time
yeah did he get like a memo where it's
like your district just became d plus
eight so now you better be a democrat if
you want to win
i think he got a lot of opportunities to
be on msnbc and cnn and
loved watching himself on tv
you know you don't nobody his
constituency has not seen him at all
he's been
not even a conservative since you know
in 2014
even and that was even before trump and
all that i mean he's made
a a career now out of being a politician
and one that particularly
bashes trump the liberal media loves
that because he goes on and
hey look we have a republican that
doesn't like trumpism he's our token
uh republican and and that's just not
you look at people on the ground and
they're like what is this guy doing this
is
not no he that's not leadership by any
means you are
he he's driven by his own ego in his own
career
i completely agree yeah i think this
technology is given
has given opportunity for corporate
fascism to thrive
and like it's also given an opportunity
for young people to get involved in
politics in a different way which is
cool because
if we do take our control of our
government
that's i think that's a positive outcome
for this experiment but if we don't the
corporations will
with their with their advertisement and
then their brainwashing and their
poison and well that's that's what's
happening right
corp the the corporate america is as
woke as they get
yeah and so they are we talked about the
other day like the punk rock bands lit
around the sides
side of amazon and and walmart if you
i'm sorry i just got to say this
bad religion i was such a big fan of bad
religion you're on walmart's
side so i don't know what that means
what's their song
they did a song that was supposedly
anti-alt-right but it was actually very
pro-alt-right and it was the weirdest
thing ever
and they got criticized by some leftists
because they were like was this song
criticizing white nationalism or
supporting it we can't tell
i don't know yeah yeah it's just it's
it's weird times
it's the realignment i guess it is but
you know there's disruption in every
in every uh industry and every part of
i think life too and you're seeing that
now i think in the political space
especially and i think it's
it's a good thing you know again i've
never seen more
like people all you know a lot of my
friends who are running now
these are true servant leaders like
these are people who
want who have left their everyday lives
their jobs in the private sector left
the military
or even left their families and they're
like you know what i'm sick of the way
things are going
and i want to to take back the power for
the people
and and be a good representative and and
you're seeing that happening all across
the country now and
i think that's the positive side of all
this in 2007
i was making youtube videos and i got
this really like
strong feeling that we needed to
globalize that there was no
stopping it it was just what's happening
is the entire globe is coming together
with the internet
and we have to build a government that
can sustain that
and it didn't happen i didn't push it
that hard i kind of had a nervous
breakdown instead because everything was
so psychotic for me at that time um
so so but what's happening is it's
happening anyway but we don't have a
government to stop
it or to take control of it so the
chinese corporations are like
driving people insane in the united
states they're you know
all this global collusion that is just
on let me let me
let me interject and try and see if i
can thank you wrap up a little bit what
you're saying because
because you're right um basically there
was that there's a famous quote i think
it's from
was it nathaniel rothschild or something
that globalization will happen whether
whether anyone wants it to or not and a
lot of people took like a threat like he
was saying we must have you know a
global one-world government or something
i think what he was saying was that it's
going to happen through
trade unions and communications the
issue is
it it's it's we already do have one
world currency
it's called visa and mastercard go to
any country you can swipe your cards it
works
to buy stuff the swift payment system
and we already have international
agreements
it's not a legitimate like one world
system
however we still have our borders our
rules just like you have your own city
with your own cities laws the united
states has its laws
and even though there may be
international trade things like that and
some people may believe it's inevitable
we still have to maintain that when
you're here we have a constitution we
have rights
right it's one of the most amazing
things and i every day i look at what's
going on around the world and i'm just
like
thanking the founding fathers that being
said
because we are not having the values of
the constitution
be the superseding culture right around
the world china is filling that gap
now you have major corporations united
states who
they're deferential to china because
they don't want to lose money slavery
absolutely these billionaires who are
like
hey guys don't criticize china taking
over hong kong like what are you doing
we don't want the nba to sell shirts to
say free hong kong why
because people involved make millions of
dollars from china
it's basically like it's it's really
really simple
chinese enterprise goes to wealthy and
influential americans and says
we can make you even more wealthy and
they say deal there
there it is they were bought and paid
for the emancipation proclamation is
legit
like we need to broaden that to the
world and and like child slavery child
labor laws from the early 1900s we need
to bring that around the globe
because eight-year-olds shouldn't be
working 16-hour days anywhere on earth
well now you're getting a little bit too
big for where this conversation was
going i mean look
the issue i'm talking about is what i'm
concerned with is a supremacy clause i
don't want a global supremacy clause
like we have in the united states a
guaranteed bill of rights for everybody
well maybe we do need something like
that then that's
the problem is we are in this bubble in
the united states
where the constitution is a force field
taking active fire and eroding before
our eyes yeah
you look at what's going on in ontario
did you see these videos out of ontario
they basically said you can't leave your
home unless you like
unless you have permission or whatever
and the police can detain you
and ask you what you're doing outside of
your house eight hundred dollar fines or
something like that
they were saying in the uk like earlier
last year that you couldn't
have adult activities with someone you
were just meeting or something like that
you can't go on holiday it's a five
thousand pound fine here in the united
states
they would love to silence our speech
guess what we got
what did dave chappelle say the second
amendment is just in case the first one
doesn't work out i love that
well what's in to your point about the
two-party system
i swear i have a point here it's now
evolving into you know where the
republican party or conservatives are
the only ones respecting it seems like
the constitution
and we've gone so far to where we are
now
where that constitution is eroding and
it's like who is upholding these values
and to your point about big business you
know our founders they didn't want big
government
why would they want these gargantuan
monopolies
dominating they're just as controlling
as
a big government would be right and
and that's super concerning and then you
also look at the populist movement
though like what happened in brexit
or or even the trump movement people
are are craving for nationalism they're
craving for
a structure and thank the lord that we
have our constitution
we need to preserve it at all costs
they're doing everything in their power
the establishment to destroy it
right that's why i'm saying it's like
we're we're all these small little
children underneath the big blanket of
the constitution
and they're the monsters outside our bed
and we're being protected
but sooner or later they're tearing
through it yeah they're they're ripping
it away piece by piece i don't like
forcing things on people in general but
the constitution was kind of forced on
everyone in the united states and maybe
we do need to force something like that
on the globe
i don't know about all that how do you
do it yeah
the issue is to adopt it that's that's
the idea of nationalism
which is we have a constitution we have
our rules we need to protect that
and other people can do what they what
they want in their own country i guess
military it doesn't have to be military
aggression
force there's other ways to force like
use the force
uh to get people to adopt a new way of
thinking i mean look man that that kind
of that kind of
stuff didn't work we were trying to go
geez force yeah
well air dropped blue jeans into
afghanistan and then none of that stuff
works they said blue jeans
what was it blue jeans ended the cold
war was out that i didn't hear that yeah
and then was it gorbachev yeah i think
so
yeah weird well you have joe biden
coming out saying no
no amendment is absolute this is amazing
he was talking joe biden was talking
about the second amendment
he said no amendment is absolute and
ever since the inception of the
amendment there are some people who
aren't allowed to own guns
you know who those people were who
weren't on guns when the second
amendment was was drafted
oh i do yeah slaves not a good point joe
biden
but not surprising coming from joe biden
yeah no exactly
giving a speech downstairs and man well
we
we actually have a another story here on
biden check this out
ted cruz says biden's comments on
chauvin verdict are grounds for a
mistrial
he's right we saw it with maxine waters
she made these threats
over the weekend and the judge in the
case said i'll give you this the defense
congresswoman waters statements may give
you something on appeal and could
overturn the entire trial
then we had joe biden come out today i
think it was today and he said
he was he was hoping for the right
verdict because the evidence was
overwhelming
now i don't know if that's ground
necessarily for a mistrial because the
jurors were already sequestered
but the idea that the the democrats were
making public statements
influencing absolutely yeah you got
these jurors man they know their house
is going to get burned to the ground
unless they give the
the extremists what they want so they
did there it is
there's no justice there's no fair trial
here well and then going back to the
business stuff it's the same way i mean
are they
our business is going to be boycotted
then if you know if they don't comply
to a different a policy initiative or
what is going on in the in current
events or the political space
when i see people talk about censorship
and the weird can't like cancel culture
stuff
and they laugh about it yeah in a sense
where it's like they're not laughing
because they think it's funny what's
happening to people they laugh because
it's like it's just so absurd these
people are crazy
i'm like you realize that level of
social enforcement
where they're censoring speech they
don't like right where they're getting
people fired from jobs because they
spoke up or
stood you know stood up that's how
authoritarianism begins
you know i often say we in the context
of reading say 1984 or brave new world
or fairness
451 did everybody reading those just
assume
in those worlds one day blink there was
an authoritarian government
just like you wake up one day and
there's a guy in the screen saying i am
your dictator
no it happens gradually through social
acceptance
and social pressure the only reason the
government has powers because people
have confidence in it
so when you get to a point where
everyone's like i will either say
nothing
or i'll join the mob congratulations you
are you are on that roller coaster
heading right down into totalitarianism
yeah i i kind of actually feel quite
sympathetic for the jurors
people have people are saying like you
know they're pansies they're being
pushed around and i don't think that's
the case
i i i agree that they could be much
stronger but i also sympathize that
they're concerned about what's going to
happen to their homes
and their kids you know their families
but
tim seems to disagree i think about the
founding fathers
and i don't even know the number many of
the people who signed the declaration of
independence with their homes burned to
the ground yeah you're right
they were killed and there are people
right now
could you imagine like if like george
washington thomas jefferson thomas paine
benjamin franklin
they're like you know chilling watching
what's going on here and they're like
you know a bunch of people died
for freedom for liberty for the
constitution for the bill of rights for
the right to
individual freedoms and now you got
people who won't even say words
there's you got people that won't even
risk losing money
there are people who literally watch
their homes get burned to the ground
because they believed in something and
today in america you have people who are
like
don't don't look at me i don't want to
be involved i'm not sticking my neck out
for anybody
so this is a point i made to catalina on
the drive back um i don't think that
we're going to be able to actually win
this war
or get our culture back without being
inconvenienced
we are in love with convenience we like
everything to be soft
and easy perfectly temperature
controlled we
have serious first world problems and it
is biting us in the butt
you know what i think you know i think
it is i'll say this was that in 17
you know in the 1760s up to 1780s enough
stuff with all the revolutionary war
there was no air conditioning yeah so
everybody was already drenched in sweat
and grime and all agitated
yeah so they were just ready for a fight
it's like you're sitting there
you're in south carolina you are
sweating
like crazy and then you get a letter and
you open it you're drenched in sweat
and it's like we are taxing your crop
independence banging on the table now
people are sitting there in their
massage
chairs watching nobody the new movie on
amazon prime with a uh deep dish pizza
overnighted from chicago to wherever
they are
and they're like i mean this is nice it
could be worse
because it's not impacting their lives
but then you see
look what happened with robin hood and
gamestop and
uh even the the twitter censorship right
when it affects people's lives
personally i think that's when people
start kind of waking up and wanting to
have a voice and saying that
look i this is not okay and
uh you do need to push back but i think
a big thing too is that like our
generation just really doesn't
uh i think our hit history of our
country
and the fact that you know in the 40s we
were fighting fascism we were fighting
nazis and even in vietnam right i mean
we have
our our country has been a beacon of
hope
and fighting the the real ideologies out
there and the real threat
of authoritarianism uh
decade after decade and yet and then
even
our founding in the fabric of how we we
came to be america
why is that being lost in history why
aren't millennials scared
to the core of communism and
socialism and then we're crazy because
we ca we
come out and we say this is absolutely
this is absurd that we're even having
conversations like the green new deal
or even what's happening now with the
political unrest
well the the us fought the nazis like
you said we we as a country
we're engaged in war and there was a
very uh atrocious
uh political faction and factions the
axis powers
and then we had the cold war yeah so we
were constantly in this ideological
battle where we had to protect ourselves
and then after the cold war or actually
with with nixon and some of the other
administrations coming up to the end of
the cold war i guess the u.s decided to
open up trade to china
maybe out of fear that if china went an
allied with russia more seriously than
we'd
have lost the cold war or something like
that now
the great ideological battle is the us
versus china but we don't have national
unity saying we must fight and resist
china the chinese communist party
now it's just a bunch of billionaires
saying stop criticizing
china come on you know just buy our
stuff
one yeah that's a great point but i also
think about we were in
you know the war on terror for 20 years
when europe not only in the military or
even public opinion
we look at when we get into these
conflicts and it's like did we even have
a goal
i mean why is this going on for 20 years
and now we're gonna talk about
uh political unrest globally again
i mean it's it's it's almost a lack of
leadership
uh and in different administrations that
i think have really caused this
and even congress to a fault and just
just the
i don't want to say it's not complete
incompetence
but it's definitely agenda pushing from
within
that has put us in this position now
like with china i think we don't have
leaders yeah
i think that's the the big challenge
there are a few
uh that i can easily name in terms of
conservative leadership and it's people
like steven crowder and tucker carlson
yeah but they're not in politics right
if could you imagine if crowder was
like in the senate oh yeah like he'd
actually be doing things
right instead he's you know well he's
doing something maybe arguably more
important by being an influential voice
and i was we were talking about this
actually in the drive up it's just how
um
everybody i think has kind of their own
gifts and their
their role in civic duty in a sense and
i think journalists and
and people like tucker carlson and even
you guys i mean
they're such a everybody kind of has
their own way of of kind of
serving right serving others and
and serving you know the fabric of our
country in a sense here within and
you know every again um i think
president trump
was a great leader i think in a lot of
ways he stood up and he was the fighter
that
a lot of people wanted and i think now a
lot of people are
craving that in in at all levels locally
and and they just want somebody who's
not afraid to stand firm and stand up
and fight for
and be principled unlike the republicans
leadership now which are like
just wagging the finger at maxine waters
but i will say
uh of trump he was absolutely
a fighter he was loud bombastic
tweeted like crazy but people accepted
that they finally had someone who was
fighting on their behalf so
what did the left say he was a strong
man he was a dictator
oh i'm sorry man donald trump being loud
bombastic and kind of erratic is better
than joe biden stumbling down the stairs
and being unable to negotiate with any
of these countries
just being weak trump was far from
perfect
but at least he was just over the
threshold of actually doing things and
fighting for things
i think a problem is like i keep
thinking about eisenhower how he
basically acknowledged the
military-industrial complex and they
deferred leadership to this quiet
secretive organization that deep state
is somewhat running the government
running the world with military bases
establishing this liberal economic order
around the globe
yeah um so a real leader would stand up
and say i'm gonna break this apart
and get killed because they're they're
in the crosshairs they're vocally
speaking
they know where they work they work at
the white house um
and they stand no chance they're
surrounded by people that are working
for that system the the military
industrial complex it's
so a real leader it's almost like you
don't see them like
but we want someone to step up and speak
and we want that person to be the leader
at least i do
it's inspiring but in modern days when
the leaders are be
in the shadows and i use the word leader
in in an odd way the people that are
making the decisions yeah
maybe aren't this maybe that's the
leadership
system oh and that's the same thing
about with eisenhower it's like he was
on the ground with his troops right you
read every type of servant leadership or
leadership book whether it's business
or military the best leaders are
there on the ground with their people
and the issue
especially now when you bring up the
establishment to kind of like tie
everything together
we were talking about earlier is that
these people sit in their ivory tower
and they're in dc you have these
bureaucrats you have these people that
are in a far away place as reagan used
to say
and they're not in tune with the
everyday american
they're not in tune with what people
want and and what
where the country is going why are our
manufacturing companies are getting
shipped off to china
because our politicians don't understand
small business owners and they don't
understand how their policies are
affecting
everyday people in everyday lives and i
think that's the biggest issue we don't
have enough people on the ground
yeah i would love to see a president or
like a leader get on like a video chat
conference with 30 other people and just
and listen to them all right for like
two or three hours a day
right well the the the two big issues
that i see
one economics obviously under donald
trump yeah the economy did really well
in 2019 it was kind of a crazy year just
everything was going so great for so
many people
and then covet happened which then
everything kind of went really bad for a
lot of people but under trump the
economy
when things were not you know coping but
you also had the critical race theory
stuff which is now becoming more and
more pervasive
donald trump signed those executive
orders i don't think he understood the
problem enough
but he still took action and now you
have joe biden basically
going as woke as possible rescinding his
executive orders and now it's gonna
start getting
uh it's gonna start getting really
really bad i mean these people are
overtly racist and the the policies that
they push
are incredibly divisive so i have to
wonder because we've had this
conversation with china uncensored i
think and james lindsay actually
where you know what is china doing in
terms of the wokeness
and and the culture war and it may be
that they're exacerbating it they're
trying to
so while they're extracting our
manufacturing base in our and in our
economy
they're also helping to seed an
extremely divisive and racist
uh ideology which in my opinion is
antithetical to
the the constitution and you know what
americans believe but that is becoming
more more pervasive
you get someone like joe biden you get
someone like kamala harris and that's
and that's it it's gonna start spreading
it's gonna get worse
and then we're going to see more and
more democrats that embracing this stuff
you start seeing even some republicans
you know
start to dance around this kind of stuff
and then eventually you'll have a bunch
of weird cult dogma ideology
which as far as i'm concerned may as
well be a religion and it's going to be
infecting government
and we were talking about the worst flow
state yesterday you ever do meditation
absolutely love meditation this this
this racism and this this weird ideology
that you're talking about it's like it's
infected the mind and it's making people
think on overload and overload maybe
it's not making it but it's that's what
they're
so when you can clear your mind that's
the way out
i think i think people are
what's the right way to put it they i
think deep down many people know
it's an it's an inherently evil and just
like corrupt ideology
but they know that if they speak up
they'll be canceled they'll be
threatened
so it's like the jurors you know what i
mean they're like i'm not going to say
anything because i don't want my house
burned down
there's a lot of people who are like i'm
not going to challenge the the woke
you know establishment and this critical
race theory stuff because it'll destroy
my life in my career
but then you look at someone like you i
mean you you talk about it almost every
day
and complain about it and your career is
thriving so and that's why i keep
telling people to start doing it start
standing up
because it's it's it's it's i don't i
don't know exactly where the quote come
from comes from i will tell you that i
i think i accidentally made up a quote
from andrew breitbart
where someone told me this they said i
was told that breitbart said this and he
didn't but it was
you walk towards the fire and it's scary
at first but on the other side is
freedom
and so you have all these people who are
seeing this fire and they're like i
can't do it i can't it's bad
and then i'm like watch and i run and i
jump jump over the fire jump through the
wall and you're fine
jump right through no problem and
there's freedom the other side we're all
hanging out we're all we're all free
no no one can do anything to us they
can't take anything away from us
we've built something new that is ours
but you have to keep moving when you get
close to that fire because if you stop
when you burn and you panic you're gonna
burn to death and but
is it does it all come down to and
almost to bring in the meditation aspect
as well and like the self and the ego
and all that
is it a courage issue right and like
a lot of people you know our country was
founded upon individual liberty personal
responsibility to to take risks to be
whoever you want to be there's no
ceiling
you know you define who you are you
define your own destiny
but then we've slowly eroded into no you
must comply
you are in this social order you are you
know even with the school system
you know you kind of have to fit this
mold and are are we as a society
just so um have we just been so
kind of led on onto this
kind of social structure this is the way
things are supposed to be therefore we
we shouldn't speak out we shouldn't have
the courage to speak out and then it
goes back to kind of like meditation
is that are we all just striving to kind
of unlock that courage and
unlock that that self and get rid of
that ego and stand firm and and kind of
move forward and i think
more people need to do that yeah sure i
was growing up in public school system i
was always afraid to speak out
hand up yeah i didn't want to get in
trouble that was a big part but i don't
want to get in trouble
and taking psychedelics opened my mind
and made me realize how powerful i am as
an individual
uh especially marijuana was the first
one uh psilocybin
and the government has made those
substances illegal for a reason it's not
a weird coincidence like those are
powerful
individual creationism tactics to use
chemicals in life
and it it's very dangerous for the
natural order to to constantly have
upheaval so i understand why
why they're they're controlled in a way
but to our detriment as we can see as
psilocybin is just made legal in dc like
and used for ptsd and i'm sorry you said
it looked like you were about to say
something
no but um we can talk you you were
mentioning something before because we
were just talking about the critical
race theory stuff yeah or say i brought
it up but you were mentioning something
about
schools and like furries and things like
that yes
so you have so there are a lot of
different states passing bills now
um that critical race theory and all
this critical theory in general i
suppose
right being it's now being implemented
at a state level perspective and then
the school boards can either determine
whether or not they obviously want to
to encourage it but there's a huge
problem because then again
you get back to being bullied and and
bullied into submission
and if you're that one parent that
stands up and says
i'm not okay with my child not only the
teacher talking about this stuff
but my child having to comply and sit
there and listen to this
are you then you know your your house
being burned to the ground because
you're one parent that had courage to
stand up for their child and then on a
state level when you have your own
your elected officials pushing this and
a state perspective
where is the control right who does have
the power to get that stuff out of our
school systems the parents should
the school board should not the state
what's interesting about this stuff is
that because
critical theory is a religion but it's
not recognized legally as one
it's basically them putting religion
into the schools into the public schools
right these are people who believe
insane things
that aren't true they believe things
that are not based in fact or history
and the teachers are teaching it they're
creating diversity inclusivity and
equity positions at
uh corporations this is religious
it's non-theistic religion so now it's
in schools dogmatic
right and then who determines especially
in a company
who determines what the criteria is if
you're not complying with their
diversity and inclusion and
you're you're welcome priest the woke
equivalent of one right the
the uh uh the chief diversity officer hr
lady
acts as the internal party member to
tell you what
you know is right or wrong but uh more
specifically
correct if i'm wrong but you were
mentioning something oh yeah furries and
things like detecting
yes is this true school yes schools
protecting
uh furries this has happened yeah i
won't name the school
but this actually happened uh and
it's very similar to kind of the the
gender things as well
um if you if you are in
if you're a teacher and you don't you
know refer to somebody as their correct
pronoun or now a furry for example
uh you could be fired or you can be in
trouble suspended whatever it might be
for those that aren't familiar with what
if you guys all know what furries are
right
yeah but enlighten me so they're
basically people who
have some kind of that identify with
anthropomorphic cartoon animals so they
have and some people refer to them as
like
fetishists others say it's just more of
an identity thing
but the reason i thought this was
interesting when you brought this up
before because i've talked about this
that under
the new york city human rights law it
does provide legal protection
legal protection to furries so people
who
want to wear a fursuit to work under the
law should be legally allowed to do it
the law states at least in new york uh
that gender identity is self-expression
and that you cannot be discriminated
discriminated against based on what you
wear
what you call yourself and for good rea
like for obvious reasons right if a
transgender person
is you know where if it's a someone born
male and then
they they identify as female and they're
wearing a dress and they say their name
is susan
the idea is the business can't
discriminate against them based on those
characteristics
but then it opens the door for things
like furries and and i think the the
interest the thing about furries is that
it's interesting because it's a
recognizable
identity group of people that is i mean
they have they have conventions there's
a there's a lot of them
so you can't act like it's not real and
they're protected under these rules so
you know earlier before the show you
were mentioning something about how like
a school
there was like a teacher i guess who
didn't want to do it or something well
yeah
and i won't name it but yeah a teacher
was like i cannot believe that i
you know i could get in trouble because
i call this person by their name
and not by their you know furry fursona
fursona i don't know
so you could never hear what that is
until this particular
instant and it's this is happening
in a lot of different places this is
happening in states all across the
country
and well particularly more blue states
for
you know obvious reasons from a policy
perspective but this is happening a lot
and like and parents probably don't even
know
and then their kids have to deal with
the stuff at school i mean it's just so
it seems so bizarre to me i think there
may be a light light
at the end of the tunnel homeschool your
kids right
this is going to encourage more and more
parents to get out of the public school
system
everything the left has been doing has
been pushing this country in my opinion
closer towards and kappa stand
where where defund the police okay we'll
hire private police
we're gonna we're gonna indoctrinate
your kids in your schools then we're
gonna create our own school pods and
pull our kids out
it's forcing families to basically
privatize things and
you have so many moms or parents that
were never even political at all
but then they see this stuff
infiltrating from a political
perspective
and they're like wow i need to get
involved because this has gotten to a
point where it's
affecting me and my children and and
that really kind of wakes people up as
well i mean i hear this all the time on
the campaign trail
they're like i never followed politics
until this stuff was happening
uh and so there that is the silver
lining this is
very stuff like little kids that were
sat down in front of like teletubbies or
like cartoons with like a broken family
i think so i don't know about broken
family but i think if someone identifies
with anthropomorphic cartoon animals
i have to imagine that they spent a
decent amount of time as as a child
watching anthropomorphic cartoon animals
and then built an identity
around that tiny tunes yeah if you're if
looney tunes if you're a little kid
and you're not interacting with adult
human beings
and they're putting in front of a tv
where you're watching you know
berenstain bears and tiny tunes or
looney tunes or whatever
then you are seeing cartoon animals
talking and your brain is being wired
for that
to be adult society interesting so you
build this identity
around cartoon animals that talk and act
like people
and then you get people who dress up
like that identify that way if i played
age of empires as a kid do i do you
might get to be
like joan of arc if you play age of
empires as a kid you may
end up i don't know running for office
to become some kind of political
uh politician people just need to kids
need to come
like play more outside or something i
mean this has just gotten
i think strategic games are incredible
yeah oh they are kids need jobs
kids need jobs but not not the awful
kind of jobs from the industrial era era
like hanging out with your dad and
and you know watching him yeah like
raising chickens that's what i did
yeah you're the the children should be
watching their parents work in capacity
so that's
that's that's what i mean by jobs you
feel like hey i'm going to be building
this thing
come watch and i'll show you what i'm
saying kids should apprentice right yeah
yeah that's what they used to do the kid
would watch the their parent do a
certain task and learn how to do it so
play outside
play strategy games and apprentice that
that's the key to parenting i think
there you go yeah again
as a non-parent kids
want to be like adults so they're
looking up to adults and they're
emulating that behavior
if we put kids around a bunch of kids
they just emulate each other and then
they get their their behaviors from an
amalgamation of weird youtube videos and
and you know oh she's like why aren't
you why aren't the parents saying
parents are working both mom and dad are
at work oh yeah that's true yeah
but that's or they don't realize how
powerful like media can
warp a brain right especially a young
brain yeah
this is so interesting to me because my
family got static because we were
homeschooled and everyone's like well
they need to be socialized
they need to be around other kids their
age and my parents like no they're
around adults
you know adults will show them how to
speak and how to act and they don't
really need that influence and i did
wish that i had more friends but at the
same time i feel like i did mature
faster because i was around people who
already had this developed sense of self
and to me it was a net benefit because
it's like you need that positive
influence of adults in your life not
just other kids
yeah no i was homeschooled too and i
think for
high school i was not good in school at
all and it kind of goes back to you know
everybody trying to fit somebody into a
box i think all kids
really learn differently and school is
just not for me but then i was
homeschooled and i ended up
graduating a few years early and just
really thriving because
not only are you around kind of adults
but you're also
able to kind of understand curriculum or
you know almost read and
and be outside of this kind of construct
and
and the complexities that come in a
classroom right that come with the
classroom and
other kids and things like that so i'm a
huge proponent of
school choice especially and
homeschooling and
you know every kid should learn their
own way and um
yeah there's a social aspect of that but
so you went to public school in the
beginning yeah i did
i did i went to public school up until
about high school and then by choice did
you leave no yeah you know what i just i
didn't i never
found i don't know if i was challenged
or it was just a dif
i wasn't challenged enough but i just
learned
differently and i i ended up
homeschooling and then going to the
community college
back home and basically skipping junior
and senior senior year of college
and then going straight into um
university at miami ohio
for a four-year degree so kind of did a
weird route
if you could do it again would you have
homeschooled the entire time or
do you think it helped that you spent
some time that's a good question
i don't know i would i think
probably up until elementary school i i
think public school is okay or like
being around other kids is
is fine um but then there gets to a
point where
you know all kids are learning
differently or at that time it was like
you're either put into you know higher
level classes or you're not or if you
were
a lot of it was i think it's
i guess in short i'm glad i did at least
by elementary school and a little bit of
middle school
um in the pa in the public space but
then ultimately
kind of where i needed to get serious
and i
needed to get into college and needed to
kind of
focus and thrive i was able to do that
by being outside of
homeschooled at a high school level you
use the internet a lot when you're
homeschooling
yeah definitely yeah it makes sense
that's the key man
yeah it's a secret we we are in the era
where uh
you teach yourself yeah you become an
auto diet act right is that the
project like i feel like i was such an
avid reader as a kid and like
always kind of wanted to explore other
topics and
and i just did not conform to this
um kind of uh
just this the the structure of
public school and just what they wanted
to to teach it just was not
my thing but i did they say nasty things
about you where your teacher's like if
you don't do this you're going to end up
working at mcdonald's oh yeah absolutely
i was like it was crazy i was at i think
like a junior level reading
level when i was in like third grade or
something crazy like
and i only say that because in this
school and in some public schools you
have teachers that
they they look at kids and they're like
well you're not smart enough
and you're not that well my test scores
proved otherwise i just wasn't
you know good at school i guess yeah and
and that really hurts self-esteem
because i knew i was smart but i just
never
uh but when you have people telling you
that you're not fitting a mold or you
don't have teachers that are encouraging
you in a positive way
which i had great teachers but i also
had kind of bad ones like every kid
right
um and you can talk about this i'm sure
from a homeschool perspective
is um when you have people at such a
young age like not encouraging you or
not wanting to
kind of one-on-one or help you from a
learning perspective and that's where
the parent comes in and my parents came
in they're like you know what you're
you're not doing great in school let's
we know that you're smart but let's find
a different avenue for you
that's where the parents have to take
that responsibility right
um but it does it does hurt your
self-esteem when you're a kid and
because they're like well you're
different from them i kind of had the
opposite
uh reaction when i was in school and i
would do well on tests but just not care
for the homework
just got more arrogant the more they
told me i was wrong i was like
you you so i remember i had one instance
in math class when i was like in seventh
grade or something
and it was like a really stupid problem
like 30 minus 50.
and i was like dozing off not paying
attention to my teacher is like who can
answer this question
and then she calls on me thinking she
got me and i look at it and i'm like
negative 20.
and then i go back to like doodling
stick figures and then she demands she
demanded of me like what's the formula
and i was like formula for what like how
did you come to the answer
that you know 30 minus 50 is negative 20
and i was like
because the three three minus five what
do you mean like it's just arithmetic
like it did in my head
yeah and then i got in trouble i got
detention because of it and so i was
like this just proves these people are
morons because i can do it instantly and
they can't
i the biggest frustration of mine i
remember i was chewing gum in school i
think i was in middle school or
something
i was chewing gum and i forgot to spit
it out before getting into class
and i did it twice i guess in the same
week
my teacher deducted from my grade
because i was chewing gum and at that
point i was like this
is unacceptable you are a teacher you
are here to teach me the subject you are
not here to discipline me over
gum this is communism and i freaked out
i swear i was like this is
at that point i was probably in middle
school and i was like
at this point this is un i'm like you my
i'm
being punished from a grade perspective
and
because i i was chewing gum how how
hilarity is it that how hilarious would
it be to see
13 year old catalina screaming at the
teacher this is communism
telling me not to chew gum is communism
i love it no but it shows that deducting
your points
wasn't about your your skill or
abilities right it was about you being a
perfect little drone and doing as you're
told
exactly and then you know nobody that
everybody that did what they were told
got perfect grades that's communism pass
you through school
i had a class in college that i never
attended i think i attended the first
day and then just stopped going i missed
the the midterm
uh test and they were like it's an
automatic failure i was like hey i went
in i talked to the guy charmed him and i
was like
can i somehow do anything pl to pass and
he's like if you can get an a on the
final i'll give you a d
and pass you so i studied i got an a on
the final and they passed me
totally against they just liked me it's
it's
i don't want to swear but that whole
system is rigged and jacked
in my opinion it's so easy to get
through it
if they like you and it's like you said
they'll just if
you're arrogant they just want to
destroy you because they're they're ego
maniacs
and then think about the political stuff
sorry to interrupt you but think about
politics
i was very outspoken as a kid or as a
college student
at my school and i had professors that
i would get bad grades because i on a
test
if i didn't agree with them and and i'll
say that now and i'm proud of it because
i look at some
kids now and they're on campus and
they're like well
i just i really want to write the right
thing so that my
professor doesn't you know fail me
because i'm a conservative
that is a huge problem that is a a
very bad problem sounds sounds like
these conservatives are spineless
or just kids i'd rather have a d
than ever yeah i'd rather fail the
problem is they're spending all this
money
to go there and if they disagree with
their professor and fail
then they they've wasted their money
basically so they have to agree with
something they don't agree with
and and it's warping these kids into
crazy probably what's happening
yeah yep i'm so agitated because of this
this chauvin thing school cuts off the
tall grass
if you if you are young and talented
they do everything to hold you back and
try and stuff you in a box yeah
it moves at a specific pace if you're
not fast enough you get left behind if
you're too fast
you get pulled back yeah yeah well then
you're told that you're different and
then we think about i love
for example iron rand and the
fountainhead and
a lot of her books and you think about
all these entrepreneurs and people who
weren't good in school and they
you know do great things in the world
and why aren't those people celebrated
but
instead we need to protect the structure
of the public school system and protect
everybody kind of is is the same i think
that's the detriment of individuality
in a lot of ways yeah it it's communism
public education is an
incredible boon you know before we had
it it was hard to get education but now
we don't need this weird regiment
we have the internet and access to the
information
so we can still provide the boom i'll be
honest man kids should be
learning stuff way before five years old
oh yeah and so the idea that an american
kid is gonna like
sit around watching nothing but cartoons
until five and then go to school to
learn the stuff how horrible for a smart
kid
yeah well and to make it also not to
bring up
politics but to bring up politics there
was a school in illinois
and they had the worst percentage
of their kids were not reading and
writing i mean they had
the worst test scores but that
the biggest priority for them was
renaming the school they didn't want it
to be called thomas jefferson anymore
they wanted it to be called because of
the race relations and tearing down
statues and all that
that's what you're focused on when your
kids are at 11
reading at literacy rate against the
state
when did this happen this was recently
this was a couple months ago
middle school you know they were they
wanted it barack obama at a
middle school but then people started um
they pushed back on push back on that
because he didn't do enough
for her daca and immigration
again your your school is failing it was
in
a predominantly minority district so
people say well
we're against you know why aren't you if
you want to help minorities then
you know help increase your literacy
rates
increase people being able to thrive and
get out of the system
whatever it might be hold on you're no
no i'm sorry
catalina that is racist the reason they
can't thrive is not because they don't
know how to read
it's because of white supremacy right
it's very it's interesting
it's just so much easier should i teach
the kid to read or just point at ian
ian you're you're a the problem with
that and why it gets
why some people actually might think it
is because in the early 1800s when the
slavery system was there there were like
white people that had black slaves and
they were keeping them illiterate on
purpose because they wanted to keep them
disempowered
and unable to to migrate basically
they're just they're using all this
stuff as a scapegoat
because it wasn't that they were white
and black it didn't matter what their
races were they just happened to be
those people at that time
access to information is all over the
planet access to information
and poverty like these are these are
major issues that
create injustice
right access to information like the la
the lack of it i mean yeah like people
who can't access the internet
uh or or who are not able to
learn the truth about what's going on
who have bad teachers or who are forced
to go to these institutional
learning facilities and they can't learn
people who have access to knowledge and
people who
are i mean poverty is connected to that
if you're poor you're
the likelihood that you're reading the
classics and powerful books and
philosophy is
lower according to democrats though you
can't even get a license if you're a
minority
let alone access the internet so so
that's that's the opportunity thing
i think the opportunity doesn't exist
right
when quite literally it's it's an
outcome issue but the opportunity does
exist if people aren't doing it there's
personal choice involved you're making
me think about censorship and like this
whole censorship thing
is although they may think the ceos may
think they're doing something good by
keeping dangerous information away from
you they might
actually be punishing us because
sometimes you need to see
all sides of a situation mind conf is a
book people read it
and become more intelligent and
intellectual understanding the way a
psychopath may think
not necessarily emulating it right but
you must see the demon
to circumvent the demon and
i i'm i'm scared that if we censor too
much information that we'll end up
becoming whitewashed
and and basically fall prey to this
stuff when it does arise
it's like book burning i mean the books
being taken off of
the internet or you know whatever it
might be it's the same thing
you're who ultimately decides what is
what is wrong and what is that is to be
always the question is
who decides what gets to stay and what
gets censored
right and the the point that we've been
on the show several times during
the lockdown people couldn't go to bars
people couldn't talk to each other
but you could go online the only problem
is your opinions were filtered through
twitter facebook and youtube so certain
ideas weren't allowed to propagate
right creepy stuff and i'm sure facetime
does that have
and uh uh with that being said i will i
will state
um i got suspended from facebook over
the weekend what happened
i made i made a a a joke about cops
being racist
too spicy no seriously i was like uh i
i was like i'm gonna make a joke that
basically is a cop's a racist joke
and it was not that spicy at all is like
how many cops just take to change a
light bulb i guess i won't tell the joke
it was just about you know the light
bulb going black and then i
i posted on facebook and they suspended
me for 24 hours
i thought it was hilarious out of all
the things i say it's the calling cops
racist
is the is the thing that gets me all
right facebook whatever you say man
but i do appreciate that the the the the
people who watch me and follow me
don't get offended when i make a joke
like that because it's if a smart bunch
you watch this show
you know politically nuanced and
understanding and when people are okay
with humor
they're craving authenticity too and i
think and that's i talk about that
in the campaign trail a lot and why
people probably just love
you and in the podcast and why people
come to
a lot of these different mediums now and
gravitate towards people who are just
honest and authentic
and and you can still you know joke
i mean we're getting to this point where
it's like everything offends
everybody yeah that's uh that's
fahrenheit 451 isn't it
yeah that's even scarier it's like you
can't even
you can't even talk because everything's
offensive you got to get rid of the
books
in text it is i i you can't read the
room when there's
in text is my thoughts like i have been
so inundated with text in the last
16 years since like the inter internet
comments basically youtube comments
and uh 14 years 15 years that now when i
get a text from my dad
who's one of my best friends i just look
at it like every other person
i'm cold i'm i'm dismissive to it
because it's just text in my face
if there's some criticism in it i don't
hear his voice i don't
feel his wisdom i just see his profanity
well how about we take some advice from
the super chats and see what they have
to say if you haven't already you can
leave a super chat we'll try and read as
many as we can we've got a lot of super
chats
are we still online yeah yeah oh i
thought we weren't oh no no no
we have we have a multiple redundancy so
sometimes when you hear that boo boo boo
it like cuts off and in real quick oh
okay oh yeah we got super chats
people are giving us money to be able to
say things
yeah so if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel
hit the notification bell and go to
timcast.com become a member because we
will have an exclusive
members only segment coming up after the
show yes let's read we got cat
garcia who says hey guys an animal farm
the animals sat atop the knoll and sadly
realized this was the system they had
bled for
are we those animals sadly sitting atop
the hill realizing there is no recourse
for the system we helped create
man there is hope yeah i was going to
say i don't know i don't
sometimes i might be pessimistic but uh
i don't believe that you can change a
lot
really fast especially with the ability
to communicate
on the internet um horizontally instead
of vertically like you don't have to get
50 people in a room you can get 100
million people
in a room well poofy followed it up with
we're seeing we're seeing all of the
institutions that make the us great turn
to smoldering ash
that's good yeah it's kind of brutal
it is yeah oh man people are pretty
pessimistic in the chat i don't know if
i can keep being like a beacon of light
to all these negative comments
no you can free speech
i'll tell you why because we have people
like catalina who are literally running
for office
people who are like my age and i'm like
she's actually doing something that's
awesome
thank you but so are you guys and i and
i always hound in on the point of
local level school board state rep
federal
get involved be a precinct captain be a
committeeman
knock doors for people get involved you
can
change things but we need to mobilize on
a
bigger scale all right arceon says the
verdict chauvin means justice doesn't
have to exist
if you're hated enough your justice is
now a popularity contest
yeah chauvin was apparently wanted he
wanted to plead guilty to third degree
murder
because he knew it was done no matter
what he's afraid
he knew the politics of it was gonna but
he didn't
they didn't allow him to i guess they
they took a third degree murder charge
out
and then made it second-degree murder
and then he was like dude they it
it seems like a setup to be honest they
wanted this
they wanted this not guilty i'm sorry
they wanted this guilty verdict
it's such a dark it was such a dark day
for me today
and i i i saw like images of people
crying
like like grief that even though he was
found guilty it wasn't
what they were it's like it's not enough
it's like when you kill the enemy you
hate and you realize that wasn't
vengeance wasn't what made me happy i
didn't yeah revenge doesn't make that
pain go away
it doesn't work unreasonably angry says
do these jurors not realize they are not
safe from these marchers regardless of
their verdict they don't they don't get
it
well i am i'll say they're safer
i guess to a certain degree for now
turnabout turnip knowle says even my
black co-worker thinks the riots are
completely idiotic
the riots would happen no matter what
the outcome was we will see
we'll see matt adams says the jury only
delayed the inevitable
he'll appeal the verdict we'll get
thrown uh thrown
we'll get overthrown and we we will be
back where we are now
this verdict is only going to hurt
communities that will be under police
now if they did not indict
uh derek chovin the riots would have
happened anyway they would have stopped
and it'd be done there'd be no riots
right now
maybe the dante right thing would happen
but maybe that whole chain of defense
butterfly fact who knows what would
happen but
drawing it out yeah they're drawing it
out doing the trial again reignites all
that anger
so there you go
you're cheerful delhi says how can you
continue to say violence doesn't work if
today proved nothing else
if nothing else that violence does well
i guess the way i look at it is
if the country burns down and there's no
justice would you really call that
working
the system isn't working the benefit of
the individual the right to life liberty
and the present happiness is
failing i guess if you want to say in
the political sense
that they're getting what they want by
being violent extremists
well i guess the only reason that's
happening is because good good men do
nothing
good people do nothing it's it's 24 21st
century yeah i think it was like a
role-playing game if you want to play as
the evil character and just destroy
everyone and blow up all the buildings
you don't really get to enjoy the game
like there's no plot
so it's it's harder to be the good guy
but much more in my opinion enjoyable
and rewarding yeah much more nuanced we
got one for for ian
kaiser c says love you ian you make me
laugh and think my super chat yesterday
was a hulk reference but it sounded like
a jab
my apologies it's 40 to 40 degrees here
in minnesota
it's too cold to riot that's a good
point though yeah i'm glad to hear that
the winner they came out too early
mind your sarcasm and text my friend
that's part of that's part of it because
sometimes you just can't
you can't read through that all right
ipo says what you've been arguing for is
exactly what iran proposes an atlas
shrugged
you need to shrug off the weight and
leave them to their chaos
i know i've been saying it the cops
should all resign
if they don't want you there if they're
going to put you in prison for being
there
and no one is standing up for you i
think it's time to go
but i'll tell you this isn't there going
to be a like if i was a cop
and i was going down i'd quit right now
and it would feel so good to do it
a lot of them are but it's these people
are going to have a quick realization
about what what it really means
right when you don't have police there
anymore it's it's
and didn't we didn't we see that the
data
and polling of people wanted more yeah
law enforcement
and african american communities right
well no i'm sure it's all communities in
the suburbs
we have three million dollars worth of
damage in a nice suburb of illinois
nobody said anything nobody stood up
after the blm riots
nothing what if like um the cops
resigned
and then amazon police showed up that
supported the riots
and enforced the riots and made sure
they were allowed to take place they
voted for it i know but what if there
was no voting ian if you come to me and
say i vote for you to hit me in the face
and i did would i would i feel bad for
you
like if you lie that out again for me if
you if you're like hey tim i would like
to vote that you
you know throw a you punch me in the
face
and then i'm like okay and then i hit
you and you start going ah it hurts it
hurts so bad
should i feel bad for you when you asked
me to do this
i don't think so they voted for biden
and kamala harris in minnesota
kamala harris who literally solicited
donations to bail the rioters out
if private police show up and start
enforcing
uh like helping the writers i'll be like
what do you want me to say
am i supposed to stop saying but they
voted for it say vote vote for better
people
i say that all the time but bro it's
this is how this is the system just
because someone crapped in your river
doesn't mean that that's just the way
it's going to be
like you can dude if people vote for
something that is constitutional
to a certain degree i guess if if a
community says we all want this thing
who are you to tell them they can't have
it an american citizen who are you to
say they're not
that's not that's that's autocracy if
you think you can go in
to a community and tell them to live the
way you demand i think i can help
convince them
but i'm not going to command it sure so
at a certain point of trying don't you
just say dude look they really want
their homes burned down
why am i going to tell them they can't
have that that's like the apathy
who's that theirs no if you if you're
like f
dude dude if someone begs to have their
home burned down
i'm gonna be like yeah but okay well
that literally they voted for people
they thought were gonna protect them
they didn't realize or they didn't have
better alternatives which is what also
happens a lot of these big
run no i didn't mean presidential i mean
even at a city like say minneapolis or
in chicago for example
you don't have another side really
standing firm
or standing up and and people to counter
that they're like well i'm going to vote
because these are the only people to
vote for i i i somewhat disagree i mean
i get it in these heavy districts but
aoc had tons of competition
uh that were moderate democrats and
republicans and people still chose to
vote for her yeah
so it's like dude if someone is begging
to have their property destroyed
if if kamala harris is like i'm going to
bail these people out i'll put it this
way
there's a guy standing outside my
neighbor's house holding a giant torch
yelling i'm going to burn his house down
and the guy goes i don't think he'll
burn my house down i'd like to let him
in my home
i'm gonna be like dude i can't help you
you know what i mean yeah if it's that
literal okay
kamala harris tweeted send donations to
bail
these people out of jail some very
serious serious violent offenders
donald trump said i want to stop the
riots how did you miss that
because you weren't on twitter so listen
i think ian you're making the mistake
that the the people of minnesota
disagree with what's happening
um because they're showing us otherwise
from through a voting action
but i think you're making a mistake that
you're assuming people read twitter
and i follow that follow kamala's
suggestion to let the i don't think that
was people
i didn't say that i didn't say that all
right i'm actually i'm actually arguing
that people did not pay attention in any
capacity right
and then voted for the people who want
to burn their homes down and there's
nothing i could do to defend them when
they vote for it they didn't know
that they were helping the houses get
burned down if they were like
burn my house down okay let me ask you a
question ian
if a guy is staying outside of a bank
and he says hey can you hold this bag
for me and come on inside and say sure
and you walk you walk in with him with
the bank holding up in a bag and then he
robs the bank and puts the money in it
and then you hand him the bag and you
both run out together guess who's going
to prison
you yes are you being complicit by not
participating you're not going to be
able to go to a judge and be like i
didn't know what the bag was for
should i take the bag over the guy's
head no i mean look hindsight is 20 20
but there's a guy robbing a bank you're
holding the bag and you help them do it
these kamala harris and joe biden were
actively in support of the extremists
yes now joe biden did say violence is
bad several times i can respect that
but his own staff donated to bail out
the writers and commemoration
directly solicited donations to do so i
get it these people aren't on twitter or
watching the news
but they're not informed when they go
and vote and they go into over people
who want to burn their homes down
you're making the assumption that they
don't want that
that they voted for someone to burn
their house down but now all of a sudden
they don't want to happen
i kind of think they wanted this to
happen i kind of think the people of
minneapolis
like the riots of the protests maybe
they do well they need
somebody needs to lay down the law if
they don't like it then
do something about it there are protests
happening and the people of these cities
are convinced they're peaceful
protesters
and they've watched it happen they watch
these people go around outside
i think most people in these places like
what's happening
i genuinely believe that so who am i to
tell them how to live that's
authoritarianism man you vote for it
it's all yours
count me out i can't assume if they want
it or don't want it i just
i don't want to escalate i don't want to
accelerate the problem which is
the dissolution of the police let's try
this another way a community has banned
psychedelics right you think they
shouldn't do that
you think they should live the way you
want them to live
is that's authoritarianism well
depending on how i go about
enforcing that would be authoritarianism
i would make a video to try and convince
them to do it if they vote for it will
you respect their wishes
yeah but okay now respect their vote for
kamala harris
yeah i do i am not going to now say
this is why my position has become the
police should leave
the vote has happened the people have
spoken they have voted for
representatives who support the riots
and the extremism at this point the
police
it is in the best interest for them if
they don't want to go to prison
and for the people who asked for it for
them to leave
now in my opinion what'll happen is what
we saw last time when they voted to
abolish the police
the people of the city started freaking
out and calling the city council begging
for cops to come back
right but dude if you live in someone's
house
and everyone is screaming ian get out
and then you look over at your one best
friend who's like i'm not gonna get
involved dude because they're gonna yell
at me
and you're like i'm not leaving i'm
gonna stay it's like dude you should
leave
and then it turns out you're the one who
made the delicious bread everyone loved
and they're gonna be like is that ian
making that bread
can we get ian back you don't know what
you got till it's going i know there is
a value to walking out on someone so
that they appreciate
you because you're because they don't
know what they got till it's gone but
when you're talking about police law
enforcement it's not just an emotional
like i wish they were here it's like
you're skipping the first point of my
argument
if the p if there's ten people in the
house and four of them are really good
friends with you and six
vote for you to get kicked out and the
other three including you the other
three are like
i know i really like that you're here
but i'm not gonna speak up because i
don't want them getting mad at me
okay then leave no one is asking you to
stay dude
the cops are there everyone is basically
saying either get out
or i won't i do not believe in you
enough to support you that's the issue i
don't know what everyone is thinking
look they're clearly like looking at it
from the other who are defending it and
we're looking at social media we're
seeing it through social media so it's
hard to tell
i'm just talking about vote numbers dude
or they they don't want to be a part of
it because if they disagree
they're going to be ostracized or
bullied again back to the courage thing
right
there nobody's kind of standing up and
and saying no
or yeah that came up last night that
if they're disorganized and start
speaking out one by one the mob will
come for them one by one right
we got a super chat here from the one
free man who says i hope the police turn
their backs on the riots tonight
let it all burn that's what the mob
wants this wasn't justice this was a
sacrifice
i'm just saying this man if the people
say ian would you please leave
who are you to say no i i would i would
leave
they voted to abolish the police they
voted for kamala harris and the cops are
still there like i'm not going anywhere
well now kim potter gets to go to prison
next
who's next it's going to be some 28 year
old cop who just got out of the academy
or whatever
and he's going to be driving his car and
then someone's going to cut him off he's
going to crash and hit somebody and
they're going to pull him out of his car
they're going to beat him to death
or some other extreme psychopathic this
was a video game and i could reload my
save game yeah i would do that
get rid of the police watch them all
suffer and then laugh about it and then
reload my game so that people aren't
suffering anymore but i don't want
it to evolve devolve into anarchy ian
we're not laughing at them we're
definitely not and my heart 100
goes out to the people who will be
suffering because of this but
tim's right this is something that they
voted for if they didn't know that
kamala harris tried to get these people
out of prison
that's their fault you are supposed to
do your homework before you vote
i sure right like i was paying attention
i was plugged in
everybody should be and the same way
with you i mean any of these
maxine waters i mean these people their
comments matter
and if if for on a conservative side if
our comments
matter then the the they've said worse
things
yeah uh somebody needs to be held
accountable
at the end of the day and and it goes
back to the voting and you're going to
vote for someone like kamala harris then
understand that voting has consequences
i i view the cops that remain as like
scabs yeah you know what scabs are
yeah those are the people that if a
union goes on strike they'll hire like
random people to fill the jobs and those
are called scabs so a lot of good cops
left
because for one many of them no one
they're not wanted many of them don't
want to be the next sacrificial lamb for
the for the
cult of wokeness and many of them are
like if you if this is what you want
you'll get you know i'm not then you can
have it
but there's a bunch of them who are like
it's paycheck i'll be fine
i will prop up a system of psychotic
behavior and destruction and violence
and
make sure that people don't you know
don't realize what's going on i'll i'll
be a part of that system that to me
that's insanity you get this kim potter
woman
and this guy with aggravated robbery
armed with a weapon
and she shot him and now she gets to go
to prison for it
they are telling police officers in no
uncertain terms
if you try to make an arrest and
a mistake happens it's felony assault
and murder
so how long until the next dopey
minnesota cop who thinks he'll be fine
is arresting someone and then that
person starts screaming
and shouting and fighting literally
resisting arrest
and then trips and falls hits his head
and dies and that cop gets to go to
prison
hey so all these cops look man i'll put
it this way by all means all the cops
there can stay
who am i to judge but i will not be
defending any of them in any capacity
when they when they're the next to line
up for prison
i'll laugh honestly i i will defend them
if they were like a rider was throwing a
brick throw a
window and a cop grabbed him and then he
tripped and fell and broke his head and
then died and the cop
is on trial i would defend that cop i
would defend the the the principal
or the individual to an extent if you
are
standing there watching this happen and
you think you will be
fine let me tell you a joke ian
religious joke oh there's a guy in his
house this is
i love this one and he's watching the
news and they say dangerous storm is
coming get out while you still can
and then the rain starts pouring very
very heavily and then all of a sudden a
car
he said you know he's sitting there
watching and so
he thinks to himself i'll be fine if
anything bad happens
the lord will save me and then all
sudden you know car pulls up they come
to the door they bang on the door and
they're like you got to get out of here
quick get in the car the storm's coming
the floods no no no
the lord will save me and the guy says
no are you nuts come on get in the car
he's like i'm going to be fine i know my
faith in the lord will save me
and so they're like all right they get
in the car and they leave the water
rises
his first floor begins flooding so he
runs upstairs next a boat pulls up to
his window
quick get out of the house we're
evacuating the flood's getting too bad
and he goes no
i have faith in the lord the lord will
save me
no come on you can't stay here you'll
drown no i have faith in the lord the
boat leaves
the waters rise he climbs onto his roof
a helicopter
flies over god comes on later quick
climb on we're getting you out here he
goes
i have faith that the lord will save me
argues with the helicopter guy
the guys are like are you crazy come on
finally they leave he refuses
the waters rise he drowns finds himself
in heaven
and he's confused and exasperated and
then he finally gets to meet
god and he says i believed in you i had
faith in you why didn't you save me
and he goes i sent you a car a boat and
a helicopter what do you expect of me
that's the way i view it it's like you
have these people
who are literally being shown the door
every step of the way and they know
exactly what's coming if they stay in
the flood waters
sorry dude i i spoke out on your behalf
i defended you during the trial
i defended the individual officers at a
certain point what do you expect of me
i'm not gonna sit here all day every day
saying oh no the poor officers who
know exactly what is going on with the
rising flood waters stayed in the
sinking building what's the alternative
they leave and give the people what they
voted for and asked for
and it's sad that it has to come down to
them
having you know a lot of these cops they
they wake up every day because they
wanted to be public servant
and they have these jobs and they wanted
to kind of serve something greater right
and they have to make the choice
to resign or leave or not want to be
involved
how many kid how many kids you know wake
up when they're eight years old and
they're like i want to be a cop someday
and now they don't even want to pursue
that path because of all that's
happening and
it i empathize sure i mean i
totally see obviously where you're
coming from from a principal standpoint
but then
also that it's sad that it's gotten to
that point where those
those people have to make that choice
yeah i don't even think there's a
compromise in in blue flu
you know blue flu so all the cops call
in sick
that's a couple days the state just
convicted
derek chovin the state does not care if
you call in sick for a few days
the state will panic when there's no
cops to protect them
we got a super chat here from matt
volker he says every high profile person
i see calling for defunding the police
have access to private security
even the minnesota reps who demanded the
defunding
when the cops are gone there will be no
one to protect the government buildings
and then you'll see the state start
sweating bullets the higher black water
maybe yeah they would hire private
police and then we'd grow at a certain
point scenarios roaming the streets
you're you're like
trying to prop up a broken system it's
not even well the system's busted for
sure and so why you keep advocating for
something to to keep it
staying because i'm saying dude give the
people what they voted for
well stop trying to impose your will on
fire if the
minnesota police resign then you would
see police all over the
country resigning yes good that would be
my fear and then you would see
governments hiring
private military contractors to fill the
space and you know why they're getting
their heads crushed in
on this no no dude dude
if you want to live in a in a giant
concrete block
with small cubicles stacked on top of
each other and everything smells like
sour milk you can do that if you'd like
and if you want to vote to disarm
yourself you can do that if you'd like
for me once it happens around me i
choose to leave as the riots were
expanding in the philadelphia area
and the gun laws were restrictive and it
was very difficult to protect myself i
said i better
not be here because now the national
guard a thousand have been called into
philadelphia
was not smart to stick around that's
true for any resident of any one of
these cities
you choose what you want to do if these
cops all start resigning i'm not worried
about black water showing up in cities
we have a second amendment the people
who who are standing up and staying on
principle
probably aren't all that worried all
that much either the people who are
staying in these cities and are giving
their tax dollars to prop the system up
at a certain point i can offer you a car
a boat and a helicopter if you don't
take it what do you expect of me
you keep advocating for some way to
prop the system up to keep it in place
no i'm just saying don't rip it down but
i'm not saying rip it down
by encouraging the cops to all i'm
saying resign
it is not my will to be done if the
people of the state
said abolish the police and they did
yeah but that's like a small minority of
vocal idiots
the state voted blue dude some people
did but not everybody sure
and i i'm all about fixing cities i'm
also fixing the system
by creating lots of small cities with
magnetic rails and small communities
but i don't think just destroying it
right now faster
to prove a point you said that who said
that you're saying tell me how to resign
what you don't understand is that you
think people should live the way you
want them to live
no no okay so did the people vote for
kamala harris
some of them do elections have
consequences
yeah should they have been responsible
and know what they were voting for
well did the city council members vote
to abolish the police
yes yes yes yes yes no no should they
have known what they're voting for no
that's not the way the system you don't
even know who you're voting for you
don't need to know the consequences
you can vote for whoever you want that's
part of being okay if you don't know
that you're holding a blow torch and you
burn your house down
what do you expect of me if you
if if the city council literally voted
to abolish the police
the police should say okay i'm out give
the people what they're voting for stop
acting like they should live by your
rules
ian i'm not suggesting that no one he
voted
yes they did the police of minnesota yes
they did
who voted for that the city council last
year voted to abolish the minneapolis
police department
not not yesterday last year and then a
bunch of cops resigned and now they're
in a desperate recruiting drive
right the city council was elected by
people
who voted for them they wanted this
but they saw it didn't work so then they
hired new police well they probably were
getting backlash by
the constituents because then the
constituents are like well
what is going on here my city council
that i voted for
voted to abolish the police crime was
skyrocketing
people started calling in the city
council members and the council members
started then changing their tune and the
police department was never formally
abolished
they then said okay we need to hire more
police now the governor has declared a
state of emergency they're bringing in
cops from i think nebraska
and ohio and spending nine million
dollars because they're desperate
like the one super chat said the cops
should turn their backs i'm not even
saying that because that's one way to
put it i'm saying
at a certain point it is incumbent upon
the officer
or any individual to say i know when i'm
not wanted and they voted for me to
leave
stop trying to force your will on other
people
oh no no that's but that's not a fair
statement oh and it's also
government like two different
conversations wrapped into one what
telling me to not force my will and
other people had nothing to do with
did they vote for kamala harris they
didn't vote for the police to resign
no one did that ian they voted for city
council members did it a year ago and
realized they made a mistake and then
was trying to recognize it was like six
months seven months ago
i'm sorry to interrupt you there kelly
no you're fine let's read some more
super chats yeah what were you going to
say i've
i've been god whatever this is hot i'm
hot
all right hans says i hope people
understand when politicians call for
abolishing police they really mean
replacing the police with the military
so the federal government can control
all the states that this is their plan
oh exactly
interesting are they talking about
social workers
oh they want social workers
stanley says police are not just
responsible for themselves and the
person they're arresting but also for
the people around them on a busy street
when a possibly violent person is around
a lot of civilians
that's right uh you know what man i'm
just i'm just at a point where it's like
cops are not doctors cops are not
marksmen cops are not
brazilian jiu jitsu experts cops are not
psychologists trained in de-escalation
they have some minimal training in all
of these different areas a little bit
they go to
they get certified for their gun they
have basic first aid they know
some de-escalation techniques the people
are asking for too much
at a certain point i'm just you know
what i'll put it this way i don't care
what they do i really don't
but i'm gonna tell you this when the
next cop that gets arrested and charged
with murder because they're trying to
arrest somebody
you think i'm gonna defend them i got a
good metaphor if a guy falls off his
bike and comes in
busted leg i will triage him and then if
i see him he next week he comes back in
with
he broke his leg again i would triage
him again next week same thing
i would triage him again and again and
again forever
because that is my job and that's how i
feel right now
with this situation with the difference
is the person who broke his leg walks in
and you treat him
then the next time he walks in everyone
else who's who's inside and injured
saying no no stop treating that guy
because i was here first you should
treat me and you go no i'm going to
treat him instead good point i don't
care what anyone else thinks if he's
clogging up the system
then that's that's a system that you
gotta consider that
how about this the guy comes in with a
busted leg and everyone starts screaming
at you to stop
treating him right and you tell them to
shut up no they stop they scream at him
to stop falling off your butt right
you you're the doctor you're the one
providing the public service and the
person keeps getting hurt
and no matter how many times the people
tell you to send him away you're like
nah
no because that's for a hippocratic oath
they're not they have to trust
come on dude that makes no sense no
that's exactly what our doctors are
there for
what we're talking about police black
tsar says the masses and in fact they
supported an oath of the constitution
blacks are says the mass is not
supporting the police doesn't mean the
police disappear
eastern europe has police everywhere
they're uh
every everyone there hates south america
as police everyone their hates etc
they are simply federalized as an
unaccountable as our own fbi
our future yt
stuff says the judge should have had
waters biting all other elected
officials who voiced an opinion arrested
for perjury
he asked them to stay silent but they
ignored him no respect and totally
corrupt that's not what perjury is
perjury is when you lie under oath
contempt maybe but i don't think he has
the authority to do that so
sonny james says army recruits even more
stupid than cops
if you can't defend your own land or
self what are you defending
i call it jake gardner paradox sacrifice
for a country that won't defend your
civil liberties
or don't you did he sign the contract
did he sign that contract
josiah magnuson says can we all be
honest and admit that philip defranco is
not an objective news source anymore
uh i don't i don't really watch phil
defranco stuff my opinion of him now is
that
he probably just hired someone to do all
the news reporting for him
and he probably just reads the copy like
i i don't see him as somebody who
actually
reads the news he always struck me as
entertainer first i've known him since
2006
yeah when he was sexy phil sxe phil
mccarthy 86 says loft means run in
german great name for when you're
running for congress
luffin in my swiss dialect it's loof
oh that's awesome dragon lady says tim's
right my ax was a cop
he came home one day and cried in my
arms for hours because he almost had a
16 year old who refused to drop what
looked like a gun
we don't hear those stories awful
yeah dan end says cops are not
criminals yeah no joey martinez says
defund the police and the atf is screwed
the government will screech to a halt
what the squad doesn't understand is
some of us were built for war
welcome to america bro law and order is
such a great idea and there are many
shows about it
yeah law and order that's a great show
they're doing a new one with chris
maloney oh right yeah it's uh organized
crime
i'm excited for that sounds fun that
sounds fun i'm surprised law and order
hasn't been kicked off of
cancelled yeah right i mean
have you ever seen svu yeah stabler
chris chris maloney's character is like
a bad cop he's not a good cop
he's a good dude you can understand him
that he wants to do good but he like
routinely violates people's rights in
that show it's a brutal show
wandering mage says tim i agree with you
about moving away from cities
i disagree with the idea that people
can't afford to do be like these
migrants
better to be poor in a place safe from
riots and gangs and find a new life
i think the goal is to replace cops with
feds so a lot of people are saying
probably going to happen all right colt
seaman says
through all of this bs with the trial
and hypocrisy of the left my dad
realized that him and ian have the same
button-up shirt
looking stylish everyone and did you
hear youtube ceo susan won a free speech
award
she won it from a from an organization
she sponsored so we
mentioned that last night i'd like to
give a special shout out to your dad
great tasting
del fuego says do any of you guys have
any recommendations
on audiobooks about us history love you
all especially ian
oh that's great i love dan carlin he's
not an audiobook he's a podcast he's
fantastic
oh the great war it's not really u.s
history there's a youtube channel called
the great war
and it was like the 100 year anniversary
of uh of the world war one and they go
every
every week they make a video about what
happened that weekend very cool that's
really cool
it's not at all american history but
it's so good all right ash genova says
thanks catalina for pointing out the
hypocrisy of those who refuse to
acknowledge what officers go through
you can have issues with policing and
want reform without dehumanizing an
entire profession
yeah that's true i mean sad
all right angry waffle 2 says i want to
say the jury is cowards but i'm also
sitting on 19k
doge still on robin hood because i don't
want to close my account and be
inconvenienced
i'm also trying to avoid short-term
short-term gains tax though
well there you go handyman says the
jurors were chosen but
not for their heroism tim that's true
yep team team and ontario says ian and
tim do you do you two ever play golf
disc golf more specifically
whatever land you have may be a fun disc
golf course in order
yeah we should we should shut that up
yeah that'd be fun
yeah we should build that that's a great
idea blake larum says as a country we
need an influx of young principled and
energetic politicians to move the
country forward there are too many
lifelong politicians that keep getting
elected for no apparent reason
it seems catalina is a step in the right
direction oh
thank you on both sides what do you
think about term limits oh gosh
huge proponent term limits and somebody
needs to actually have a backbone and
push it through and champion it because
uh i think that's a big problem we have
too many i'm people on both sides of the
aisle that have been there for way too
long i mean
you're a career politician why do you
have a career out of this
go do something else let other people
step up and
solve problems and you know
it's mind-blowing to me why people are
in office for 30 years and we're all
okay and just sit around and we're like
oh it's fine keep voting for them we got
a a decent
super chat um from somebody who is
criticizing me but giving me lots of
money so thank you
says you're an idiot tim you don't know
what us minnesotans
most not in the greater nine county
metro area don't live in
we're trying especially as first
responders they're 51
vote for for everything the rest of us
are trying to fix things
yeah i could see it you're not an idiot
tim
so well people are about to criticize me
salty kraken says and i will read those
uh tim you're advocating for the left
wants demoralization then
destabilization if the cops leave it
becomes a cascading failure and marxists
win
i do not believe so i believe if they
keep waiting
then the regular people become
demoralized thinking the police are
ineffective and can't get anything done
when in fact it's the da's
if the police leave very very quickly
it'll be a shock to the system that will
force people to be
like whoa so what's going to happen is
there's going to be a very very long
drawn out period which we're in
where the police refuse to to
walk away and then the people will be
like
the cops are here though and
everything's getting worse
and then there's nothing then within a
year the cops are just considered
nothing get disbanded
i also wonder from a internal political
leadership perspective too
what are the higher-ups say in these
situations are they
i wouldn't necessarily say this
particular case but across the country
how are they either advocating for their
officers
or or not advocating and trying to
kind of save face in a lot of ways too
from a pr perspective
i think that's another angle that people
kind of missed as well
i'm concerned that what's going to end
up happening is that each cop is going
to face an instance like this and
they're just gonna be dragged out and
like tart and feather just like chovin
was and it's gonna have to be on a
case-by-case basis
if they don't quit in mass like this
david little says tim you are wrong
not everyone voted for these clowns all
the citizens have rights not just the
majority
here here i i agree yes
but i i think at a certain point like
i've said if your house is on fire
i don't know they yeah i think your
shock to the system is is an interesting
concept the it's frogs boiling yeah
if the fire turns up to 10 the frogs
immediately get shocked and jump out of
the water
if they sit there as the water slowly
boils they just die because they don't
realize the temperature is increasing
yeah i don't know alan ginn says ian
always has this problem he wants people
to live how he wants but then he gets
mad and acts like he is some free
thinker when you call him on it
ian you're a stone authoritarian
recognize this oh
i like that conversation actually
because if i am
i i would i need to see that
but max henry says i agree with ian what
tim is describing is tyranny of the
majority
a community should not be able to
restrict the rights of the individual i
agree with that
interesting
oh okay um i can't read zu zulikal says
do you ever call the cable company to
tell them that they're doing a good job
or just when they mess up now do police
keep it the good work tim castro
yeah the same everywhere i try to leave
good reviews
yeah it's like yelp a lot of people you
see negative comments and
not enough good ones negativity yeah
we'll take a couple more but this is a
good one waffle sensei says tim
is defending these cops but you can't do
it all the same way over and over and
over again
gotta get a little punk rock about it
give them what they ask for and be there
to help when they get exactly that
when i tweeted all the cops resign a
bunch of conservatives
and leftists retweeted it the leftists
were like yeah all the cops should quit
and the conservatives were saying yeah
they should quit to show the
you know to give the people what they've
asked for i'm not saying the cops
should resign in disgrace i'm saying
they should resign in defiance
of a community of political leaders who
would
sacrifice them to the woke mob while
also demanding they sacrifice their
lives in the line of duty
these cops go out there expected as i
said to be doctors
to be psychologists to be jiu jitsu
experts
they risk dying when they when when a
guy
in in a car is wanted for aggravated
robbery and has a gun
that cop's going to jail now she's
locked up already
manslaughter charge because a guy who
was wanted on an
aggravated robbery charge with a gun
jumped in his car resisting arrest
so the politicians go officer you might
die
there's not the greatest risk of all
professions i think oil petroleum
engineers have a higher risk of death
but it's a scary job now we're also
asking that in the event you do fear for
your life
we're going to put you in prison how
does that sound regarding the girl that
shot the dude
on the gun shark that was wanted for
aggravated murder or aggravated assault
aren't they suppose if a guy is
resisting arrest jumps in his car and
turns
to the aren't they supposed to shoot to
kill in that
point they're they're entitled to
there's arguments that charged
exactly because the politicians expect
the police to be
everything all at once and to be the
scapegoat for their problems
thank you for clarifying i think a lot
of it too though is it's
about the divide
i mean this is all also about i mean
think about how many other situations
that these are again very complex think
about all these other situations that
happen
but why was this one on a mass scale
publicized and then are elected
the left biden maxine waters again back
to that point
why this case yeah and it goes into this
kind of
i think greater division
tool and that's actually
i think a little bit more i think that's
this that's the scary part
is is this
public pressure and politicization of
everything
for a higher purpose of ultimate
division
it empowered people politically that's
what it's about all right let's do one
more super chat we got lumberjack daryl
says
this is for you ian i agree with your
sentiments tonight your neighbor from
the north
hello sir all right we'll do we'll do
we'll do two more super chat just
they just popped up and they're short
jeff d says i'm joining tim cast
i lost the kate awakening what is that
no i don't know well go to timcast.com
and become a member
and the last one is jason van cleave
with a poop emoji
all right pretty much sums it up concise
we are going to have an exclusive
members only segment coming up at around
11 p.m
at timcast.com so go there become a
member there's a massive library of
exclusive segments and even full
episodes check it out you'll love it we
swear like crazy
uh and don't forget to like the fun part
oh yeah definitely like share subscribe
you can follow me on social media at tim
cast everywhere across the board
we have a new instagram account tim cast
irl on instagram great
it's gonna be he's gonna have clips from
the show we also have a facebook page
tim cast irl you just search for it i
think it's facebook.comcast.irl
like that because we're gonna be putting
up shorter clips from the show you can
follow my other youtube channels
youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcastnews we also have the
cast castle
vlog channel now live with one episode
officially up
another one is already done and we'll be
up soon and we're already
going to be filming and even bringing on
a professional vlogging individual
because we're going to do a daily show
with all the crazy shenanigans in the
house so it would be fun it's going to
be awesome
so uh yeah this show is live on the
front at 8 pm so we will be back
tomorrow
catalina do you want to mention your
social media yeah well thanks for
listening um catalina lauf on all social
media platforms and catalina for
congress.com
that's my website uh you can also follow
me in crossland.net
uh i'm at ian cross and oliver i really
want to uh encourage you guys to go
check out the cast castle vlog
i think it might end up being the
biggest channel
on the internet if the way it looks
because it's because it's family
friendly
i love it it's like family friendly it's
so cool it's so cribs like
like the music and the editing i mean
it's great chicken city is coming too
yeah we we bought the chicken uh nipple
water thing that someone recommended
very very great recommendation and i was
amazed because
right now they're poets they're very
young and they immediately walked up and
just knew how to do it
i i did i was shocked by that yeah so
there's like this little
piece of metal that when you push it in
the water can come out and they walked
right up and started packing at it and
getting the water i was like how do they
know that
natural law
yeah well it has to be super simple so
that chickens can use it and i am so
excited about what we're doing with the
instagram and the irl facebook
guys go follow and appreciate my pals
work over there those super
short clips are super funny super
awesome he's putting in the work
i am sarah patchoulids on twitter please
join me in my journey to surpass
sourpatch kids in follower count
we will see you over at timcast.com in
the exclusive members only segment
thanks for hanging out we'll see you
there bye guys
you